all right friends and neighbors you know what
to do if we are live let us know we cannot go
live properly until you tell us that we're live
yeah also we know hit that thumbs up if you
like that thumbnail shouts out to my sister she
often helps us make all the thumbnails thumbnails
i don't know how to do that she spent like
three two to three hours on it she's amazing
megan alba uh are we live you guys gotta tell
us if we're live jeffrey timberton jake robles
what have you done chris charlotte
can i say i'm honored that you guys
made me the irishman but also terrified
that you were like send me this photo
and i did and it's way scarier like it's
way more intense than i was prepared for
i was like i told my sister like just stretch
his face out to make it look more penguin here
did what i could make it bigger all right guys
while we're in the chat i want to thank koi for
being here uh we're gonna get straight to it a
little bit quicker than usual and uh thank you for
everyone who's here so far uh quick shout outs to
quentin steve kenny camilla disney fan juice okay
i can't keep up right now that's a good problem
can we do slower mode on the chat it's been a
while since i don't live in a live stream in a
couple of months yeah yeah i haven't been live
in a while there's a way to there's a way to slow
it down everyone that hates me on this channel
i'm the reason we're doing this because i'm like
we're gonna be live talk so take your hate to me
i thought uh i thought this was like a marvel
movie but without the comedy yeah where's the
were the jokes or the jokes lots of jokes this
movie is actually very funny i i actually the
criticism i usually can like understand it like i
can put myself in someone else's shoes most of the
critique is actually just dumb like let me use the
word dumb don't be mean no but the dumb the people
are don't be happy you have a critique you're an
idiot but like in this case i read most the rotten
tomatoes rottens and a lot of them are really
like you didn't smile enough they're like bros
girls yeah yeah yeah dumb critique i feel like uh
did you see scott mance's tweet review i feel like
you should just come out and say it like that
what did he say he just said like i hated this
it was like all dark all dreary no point nothing
fun i hated this i just went for it and i was just
like you know what fine i first heard you if you
don't like what this is about the first time we
saw the batman uh at the screening scott mance was
there he was i'm pretty sure he never remembers
me no matter how many times i've been on camera
that's so funny i was like hey scott it's like hey
i just saw the idea like i think i know you
even though we've done some videos together i
uh i just i usually like i said i can put
myself in the position of even when you
know greg who happy birthday um hater of eternals
greg alba when he was giving his justified issues
with the film i knew where he was coming from
but a lot of these people like do they know who
batman is well the thing that i actually can
understand even though i think even though i'm
not in the camp that goes [ __ ] that uh but the
one criticism that i can kind of get on board with
if i'm being completely frank and then we'll start
getting to the questions and stuff thank you guys
i'm reading i'm also reading comments while
talking to you guys been a while we've been
live just give us like five minutes to get really
used to this koi goes live more often all the time
so the criticism about like let's talk about the
bruce wayne thing really quick and then we'll hop
into your questions and such um with bruce wayne
of being a major recluse and not putting on that
alter ego personality i think the movie justifies
it well first off like i think the movie handles
it very well and then even alfred at one point
says you know like you have to keep up appearances
he's like i don't wanna and then and then you
know when he's like he doesn't go out in the
day even when he's at the funeral there's a guy
there who's like [ __ ] billionaires who are you
like like he's not even recognizable anymore
that's how saying a guy that lives in a cave
by a butler is not so socialized but the reason
why i don't one reason why i can't fault people
for thinking that a we've been conditioned to
think that's how batman operates all the time
that's why the way it is what's up apparently
my mic is low i was trying not to interrupt
you that's fine so apparently because i think
we've been conditioned to think that that like
oh to always think that's what it's going to be
even batman begins which is an origin movie he
sets out and in batman year one the comic he comes
back to gotham with the plan to put on the persona
and to be batman like he has that as a plan so
i think because we've been pre-programmed to go
he must do that is why i think some of us some
people have a hard time getting on board with it
but for the world created here for the more
realistic interpretation and for what matt
reeves set out to do it doesn't bother me for this
take and there are versions where he is like that
my greatest like the moment that really sung for
me about that whole thing was he literally fed him
berries like a bat like when he was like i made
you some fresh berries like he's more bat than man
because yes the classic metaphor is not metaphor
the classic category of the concept of the batman
is the real hymn and the mask is bruce wayne the
mask of bruce wayne hasn't been developed yet
and the end of the movie this is a spoiler talk
this is the only warning i'm going to give you
is about him finding a reason to invent
that persona because the town needs hope
the city of gotham doesn't need vengeance since
it needs hope so he goes from i'm vengeance to
i'm batman bruce goes from i am a human being
that doesn't know what i am to i need to figure
out how to represent something beyond vengeance so
i love the idea of this kurt cobain uh obviously
inspired uh reclusive but to an 11 because homeboy
is living in a cave so uh he's going to maybe even
not invent the bruce wayne person to the level we
are but i would imagine he would in the next film
and i imagine it's going to be about him trying to
rebuild gotham as a symbol of hope and therefore
needing to be the public persona of bruce
wayne as well as it's robert pattinson the man
is bruce wayne he's a guy that walks around
being handsome and rich that can't actually
interact with society like if you've seen tennant
if you've seen uh cosmopolis if you've seen
paparazzi video the dude can do this so
i just the idea that he can't play bruce
wayne is short-sighted in the idea that this bruce
wayne would already be at this point doesn't make
any sense and i know people are like it's year two
he should not do this why he hasn't needed to he
went out for the first time to a funeral that's
not where you playboy it up i just this critique
i've had i've had a long week of this ish yeah
you engaged with too many people i did i did
this is the way the most i've ever engaged the
internet this week and i feel like bruce wayne
every tweet i put out i go no look into the
comments right now and i'm like i will find you
um how is the is the sound okay right
now guys i want to say it's because we
haven't gone live in a while but i know even
when we were consistently going live we have
so but does it sound okay right now i just want to
make sure that everything someone just donated 500
what like real 500 oh my holy [
__ ] balls 500 mexican dollars
oh mexican dollars i think is
that what mx is oh that's like uh
it's like two dollars i don't know hey no matter
what it is we appreciate you we are unworthy
that's your five that's wait look we and whatever
you guys contribute that it means the world are
like seriously these are hard earned dollars thank
you yeah it's all going to pay back koi you know
that's really fun come in here and i'm like i have
a five grand an hour retainer like matt murdock
[ __ ] here god let's get some super chats jesus
christ that's right batman never leave things like
coy's on the show i'm sorry please don't hurt
me i'm just [ __ ] like adam sandler not coach
i don't know what's happening like
how do we like that let's do it or sandler you put
out a pole let's root with that pull all righty
how did you feel about the batman 12 percent
of you liked it 54 of you loved it and uh three
percent of you gotta have it no three percent of
you weren't about it and uh for 31 you think it's
the best live-action batman movie thus far that's
great to hear good turnout i'm not gonna lie about
it you know i'm always a little bit nervous before
going live uh i even told you that i was yesterday
i meant you to come like a little nervous
about doing a live stream and then whenever
we come back i go it's the best you know these are
sometimes more fun than shooting like the other
videos there's there's a connection yeah they're
just spontaneous you don't have to worry about
editing or like keeping everything super efficient
chaos i just do weekly lives but then youtube's
like we don't like those so it kept drowning
my channel john campio yeah the boss the sound
is clean everything's characterized thanks for
the comments guys all right yeah let's read some
uh some some some stuff that came in thank you
guys for your support also i'm gonna throw this
out periodically if you have a tick tock follow
coindro he's constantly posting videos he talks
theories easter eggs breakdowns of things trying
to be relevant to that toy knowledge you know go
to tick tock tick tock coin was that your ticket
yeah i don't use tickets i like your website.com
number 52
all right we'll be up here with the super chats
in a hot second in the meantime you know what let
me pull up the live on my phone so that way it's
easier oh i like to read smarter yeah i see some
super chat action don't worry don't worry koi i'm
just trying to get you you'll get what you want
to take over get to the bat we'll get to the
joker one in a second uh we will get to the
joker appreciate the question barry cogan
that [ __ ] leaked early as [ __ ] yeah
they really did months ago yeah
that has like so many confirmations
we're is like apparently his like little brother
was like yeah her brother was like got out now
and then he tried to lean i'm like dude dude
it's too late yeah you're too late everyone
everybody knows i can't undo a tweet like that's
not where things go i can't edit it oh barry
cogan uh yeah let's break this down guys this is a
thick ass movie we've seen it three times each yep
nine hours this week robert pattinson was at our
imax screening and this guy mr schmooze over here
so i was like i was i was with your guest and they
were sitting next to me and i was like this is so
annoying you know you buy people tickets and
they're all just [ __ ] outside while we're uh
they're all gonna show up right when this movie
starts they're probably gonna be a little late
they're gonna be those annoying ass people and
then robert bennett showed up and i was like
that's how you get your [ __ ] i was meeting
people i was having a good time i was drinking
a drink called the bat outside and then i went to
pee because i know there's no moment in this three
hour movie to go pee so out of respect for the
movie i missed robert pattinson he'd understand
man if anyone's gonna get it it's our pets sure
sure all right let's get to it all right alif bae
bae roslyn you see that john yes i can love the
movie i'm seeing it again tonight i was wondering
where you see the next two films going which
villains aside from the joker do you think
they should focus on you know i didn't
actually think about this villain ever
even after watching the movie i kind of have a bit
of a hard time imagining it but i know koi is a
big champion i imagine john would really love this
i i personally would want a scarecrow to be redone
three movies with scarecrow kind of he was
never like the threat or the real like yes
and you're right you're right
when batman finds out who he is
he immediately like finds him
beats and uses his own toxin
and he's always a [ __ ] in the other one but
i love him but he's not really a [ __ ] and
dark knight rises yeah he's running the kangaroo
but anyway i want a proper scarecrow redone but
matt reeves uh touched on mr freeze out of
anyone three mr freeze with matt reeves please
uh i am going to go against the grain and say i
don't think they should do the joker next uh and
i know that is no one i don't really i'm going to
interrupt you for one sec i already didn't dribble
i just don't know anyone who we've been to three
screenings and now i've never seen anyone in the
audience get excited when that joker shows up it
should have been a post-credits scene yeah and it
also like i don't know that joker we i have had
a movie where the first film teases the joker and
then he's in the second movie we've already had
that trilogy i also think that we've had joaquin's
joker we've had little joker we've had heath's
joker which is formative but i personally want
to see some more detective-esque villains so like
if they do the joker they've kind of set up war of
jokes and riddles which i would enjoy because
that's a different take on the joker because
in war of jokes and riddles the joker doesn't
want to laugh like he's lost his sense of humor
so the riddler is trying to make the joker laugh
that's a fun different take and that's a way more
mafia take on the joker which i could see this
barry kogan take doing because apparently it's uh
he's got like a birth defect that makes him smile
all the time and he's like this mafia type dude
we've already met him in this universe in the two
years we've met the joker as a not fully formed
joker that's the rumor that being said i wouldn't
mind if we keep the joker in arkham tucked away
and he's got this foreboding behind the scenes
like one day he's coming and you do villains we
haven't seen before or we've only seen as arnold
schwarzenegger like we do villains that we've
seen in the in the big sense and what i the reason
i'm bringing scarecrow as a negative is we've had
three scarecrow movies two various levels of
happiness i think killian murphy plays a great
scarecrow in the nolan take on it but you could
do a mad hatter and do a lot of the things you
do with scarecrow with a new villain and i'd go
like a ben foster mad hatter like a very intense
manic mad hatter and then you can get a lot of
your scarecrow elements but with a new take do
you think they should redo harvey dent properly
i think that the i think the next movie should be
dent was bad i mean it's perfect aaron
redempton is like damn near perfect it's
great but i like the fact that they killed him
off and he doesn't rise to like crying lord
i would introduce harvey in the next
film as the new da because they need one
um and i would introduce uh the idea of the court
of owls looming like i would plant some seeds and
then i would do a hush court of owl's third film
and i would do a mr freeze uh i would actually do
like kind of a romance story because you'd need
um mr freeze and nora freeze i would have them as
scientists in love and he wouldn't be mr freeze
until like late second act and that way you've
got a reason for bruce wayne to exist maybe bruce
wayne's invested in frieza's technology and that
way you care about mr freeze and you care about
bruce wayne more you can do the playboy stuff
and then every time bruce wayne and mr
freeze fight you care for both of them so
every punch lands twice so i would do like i'd
honestly do a nicholas sparks mr freeze movie
separate and then put it in batman and i'd have
like [ __ ] ryan gosling i'd have a handsome
mr freeze someone you invest in someone you care
about the relationship of and then you do that
movie to uh build to the third with quarterbacks
i'm sold koi nicholas sparks is mr freeze how long
each question is gonna take this is gonna be a
six hour live stream i just want my solomon grundy
movie please that would be perfect they could
do so much spooky in this i know and he would
be like how great would that like find a way to
bring it down to earth and then have him be this
strange presence in the sewers and whatnot plus
that character has a lot of like fight for the
morality of like are you gonna be a tool for
organized crime or are you going to actually
not do that and maybe be some kind of anti hero
like i don't know if you could base a whole movie
around him but i've been dying to see a live
action opening fight and like have you know the
moments that like you know you love i love when
comic movies are like this is how far things have
come this is how much better he is at this have
that be the the you know precedent i wanted andy
circus to be clay-faced before they announced
he was alfred i thought it'd be fun to have
indy circus doing a hundred different voices i'm
gonna stop talking first question also shout out
within an hour from now when people are like
hey have you gone into my question yet and
then everyone's saying that quick shouts out
to joseph prashasga in the chat uh did anyone
else think it was too faced yes at the end i
i when i first saw his actual face i was like
they doing a weird take on harvey here i
think it's greg capullo's two face where
he staples the face onto his face i think
he's actually scarred and bring it yeah i
my favorite part of the new movies coming
out is watching your live stream afterwards
always something to look forward to thank you guys
for everything thank you brandon that's very sweet
of you thank you brandon really appreciate it why
weren't you here for our uncharted livestream yeah
why weren't you here first any of you here oh
dude our entire livestream we invited you to be
on it took off million views uncharted bigger
than the boxes live stream so many questions
came right tom holland was here we got the sequel
green live yes i'm proud of you mark wahlberg's
mustache was here but not mark wahlberg it
was uh it was not a success that live stream
laura croft's two guns showed up wearing mark
wahlberg's mustache the puppet actually there
was a guy in the live stream anthony who pitched
uh mr freeze in an ice truck and kind of like
richard kochlinski the iceman which i think
is actually a really neat take i like that lab
michael shannon mister oh yes yeah all right
yeah the pipette thanks the pipette saw this
movie in imix and got food poisoning from the
popcorn i don't know it's possible we're worth it
my ear mine is a there's a one of
koi's drinks is blocking off your
thing so i thought it's worthless worthless
worth nothing if i can't keep my corn down
yeah man uh what theater did you go to because
every time i go to amc their popcorn gets me
sick every single time no [ __ ] you still
keep doing it i just don't you just said
it like you were in a computer position
man they're like you know you get a medium it's a
free large upgrade oh [ __ ] yeah i'll get largely
large instead of getting mediums i can get large
sizes i have endured so many looks going to the
movie theaters when i'm like i i just don't
need the extra i don't need a bucket of a
drink and like you know a barrel of popcorn i'm
sorry i'll just pay a little more for less food
beautiful ending batman leading the citizens of
gotham out of the darkness with a torch in hand
i got emotional every i got emotional watching at
lol every time we have seen this i have shed tears
during that moment in particular when i when we
did our non-spoiler talk right out of the theater
when i was saying like i'm not sure if i'm
emotionally as emotionally invested in this
as i like to be and then i said like oh [ __
] i'm crying um when i was talking about that
in the review it was that moment where i was and
it's like it's not just like a good isolated scene
that only works if i'm actually invested right and
because of the fact that when he like jumps down
there and does that he's uh i love the i think
what a lot of people don't point out is also the
mirror there's a cat who's meowing and he's
not in pain you guys can't hear him he just
wants to attach it to it's just freaking much
do you hear that that is literally caterpillar
stop live streaming play with me um it's
when at the very beginning of the movie
uh when he beats up those uh guys on halloween
there's the dude who he saves who's like don't
hurt me please he's terrified of him
the dude he saved is terrified of him
and it's it's a mirrored shot where like batman's
looking down at him consumed by water and then
at the end of the movie batman's looking down at
people consumed by water as the first time i hope
don't hurt me it's yeah now it's saved me yeah and
and it's a good mirroring and that person on the
stretcher i i love that moment too because it's
that like i i don't want to leave your presence i
feel safe you're the one that's helped please let
me know it's okay to go with these people like uh
yes and to be honest that's a beautiful this
is going to be true sorry in advance that's a
beautiful this is batman as opposed to some of the
other batman's people are enjoying in pop culture
like this batman very much makes a point of not
using guns and very much makes a point of not
killing you can be left on the freeway i mean
sometimes you gotta kill the freeway but like
there there is a there's a merit to pointing out
very clearly he doesn't use guns he doesn't kill
and he's a force of hope because if he just stays
a force of fear the whole point of the movie is
he's not just vengeance and i really love that
they're they're making that the first movie like
this isn't the batman that kills and i really
like that it's the batman who laughs not yet
i think they only call him i think chris stuckman
pointed this out um that they only call him batman
i think twice in this movie he says it once maybe
the end of the batman and then um they're saying
yeah the writer says a lot but he he's mostly
vengeance yeah mr vengeance yeah mr vengeance here
there's so many great little nuances poven meyer
thank you pope meyer i honestly thought the
riddler was gonna end up being tommy elliot aka
hush who wants revenge as falcone uh killed edward
elliott for thomas huane well i think in order
because i need to remember the comic properly wait
is it actually riddler who's doing it or did they
[ __ ] or is it the animated yeah the animated
movie is the one that [ __ ] up yeah yeah and
the comic goes mislead then the animator was like
[ __ ] it we'll do the misleading yes yes yeah
yeah so i think in order for the mislead to work
you know you need to establish who the riddler
is first yeah because if this is batman's first
time meeting brothers it doesn't work that's
the point of misleading yes guys actually
i don't feel hoodwinked at all so um but i think
hush is coming no i mean like the producer did an
interview on the red carpet with brandon davis and
he was saying like yeah they were going through
like every comic and he just like matt reeves
just [ __ ] consumed every comic so there's a lot
that you could already see on display here
there's a lot of com see i thought this was
mainly gonna be like film influence movie which it
is but it was also so comic book like there's so
many comments long halloween year one batman ego
year zero especially surprisingly at the end like
there's a lot of like very iconic frames in this
yeah man they even brought the carmine falcon um
that's one of the long halloweens long halloween
tim sale yeah uh with the with the catwoman being
and the year one the diner straight from year
one like they literally grabbed a frame from year
one and then put the riddler in it which and it
also mirrors that famous art piece which is cool
because the comic mirrored the art piece first
and then he was able to frame it like the art
piece and the comic and a lot of people were like
oh it's that famous piece of art but it's also
the comic which is dope you know mel gibson would
be a great solomon grundy my k let's move on here
this is a public service announcement sold
if you love the batman and want to see more
catwoman there's a great direct video animated
film called catwoman hunted available to buy and
or rent a cat woman i want to see more catwoman
i do want to see more cats the first thing i said
walking out was that i wanted more zombie crowds
you know what i'm loving about when i go online
a lot of women i'm not saying all
women yes all women i have okay yes and
all ladies are saying this
you have a universal hive
out of context and delete everything but this
oh no like so many women i encounter are like
man that catwoman batman [ __ ] is so hot oh
it is but as as a guy living today i'm like
is this gonna be perceived as creepy but then all
the women i'm talking to are like damn it's so hot
oh my god okay we're [ __ ] loud damn hands not
cancer dude i was so i was in man he like grabs
her at the beginning when the cops coming in he's
just like he has big ass arms wrapped around no of
course that moment yeah i'm like uh how's this
gonna be okay but he's doing it to protect her
so it's hot and it's [ __ ] hot also like we
need to have like more of the bdsm community
represented in comic book movies like we have a
little taste of pegging and deadpool but there's
a lot more out there guys there's some diversity
a lot of sexual awakenings all these down on you
i've got the mask for it it's not allowed guys
no no maybe it is now oh i think they had enough
kickback we might see a little cat linger i would
love some wokeness people can get on board yeah
so kyle's heroes i love their women they do kyle
arcing in the chat wants to see a deacon blackfire
story uh come to the big screen thank you i
thought that was good i just thought that was
an interesting deep cut anyway righteous rob what
would you say is different about the batman about
this batman uh i mean most things so much for
starters to bruce wayne i think like the riddler
especially i think what's so unique about this
one is exactly it's because matt reeves didn't
want to i got this guys i just gotta hit darkness
there we go and stop recording get a little bit
of buttons on screen for a tiny bit it'll go
away um so instead of watching john frantically
let's have one more second like
a gazillion things that's right
the modesty bar at the bottom of the screen
presents you from seeing oh yeah let's give
um so yeah i mean i think that what makes this
one especially unique is the fact of how many
the way how like comics can often borrow from film
genre and then then it becomes kind of a cyclical
nature with this movie i think is what's so neat
about it because it's everything matt reeves said
it was gonna be and you rarely get that i remember
like alex kurtzman who's the guy who did uh
the mummy movie was alex kurtzman yes yeah alex
kirsten when doing the mummy was like yeah you
know i started we were going back to like the
traditional universal monsters and really wanted
to capture that spirit and you hear that [ __ ]
all the time and you watch that movie you're like
that dude's a [ __ ] lost it did not work out
for him it's not just an action movie like it's
really the horror tradition i'm like no and then
like you know freaking even even nolan talking
about tennis like yeah it's kind of like a bond
movie i'm like not really man but then then here
like this is so much more matt reeves said it was
going to be it is film and comic just combined and
because it takes its time you can really feel all
the influences i'm going to make a big statement
that i think people are going to see is hyperbole
i think this is the movie as much as logan was
that's going to save the medium i don't consider
it a genre anymore the medium of comic book film
because this was a film and like logan
walked so this could run like this is a
this is the strength of this is this is not for
everyone the strength of this movie is that the
average zealot might not like it and that is
the bravery of wb and dc for being like hey
we're gonna make something that's not for
everyone every single comic book movie is made
for everyone this wasn't like the point of making
comic book movies is to have a giant box office
so you can make other movies that can kind of
keep your entire studio moving and grooving
this was the opposite they were like we're gonna
make an art house film that's gonna be three hours
largely silent [ __ ] and score long holding shots
that's not a comic book movie so i love that this
means we get an entirely new trajectory so what's
different about this is the fact that they trusted
their filmmaker to make a piece of art instead
of something that's going to appeal to everybody
what they made was a graphic novel movie yeah
that's what i would put it one more or something
oh it's just so no john please no it's something
with just as many uh cinema references to pick
out and someone is just as many references to
classic films as it has references to comic books
when you were so greg saw it before me and i
predicted way more than because because of my
comic knowledge then i was so afraid i'd figured
out the movie so i was texting greg like oh no i
think i put together too much and greg because
he's a good friend very much was like maybe
like you did he actually neutraled him but what's
funny is i struggle with 70 cinema like i struggle
with that kind of pace and and it's so fun
though so that's that's not generally for me
but it's so that was a really great text from
gregory's like i'm never going to like it bro
i i downplayed it for many people like not
for you guys so when i decided to review
but in person where people want to get into a
conversation you could ask anyone i talked to
i downplayed it it's in my top five superhero
movies and i thank you for downloading it
because if you'd said it was gonna be my top five
yeah yeah cause i i what i really wanted to prep
people for is that it's it's not a it's not the
fast pacing it doesn't exactly capture what the
it's it's more deliberate than what the trailers
represent it's more akin to the first trailer but
the trailers still have you feeling like this is
going to be like a pulse-pounding exciting film
when i'm really like no that's more of like a mood
uncomfortable piece observant colder and then then
it gets like oh i have it has a heart there's one
like five million worked for where i think it's
like the trailers are great whereas like uh where
i think where logan you know has more of a heart
throughout and uh because you didn't feel like
i had a heart on top uh i felt like you have to
i think on a second viewing i found the heart
earlier on yeah because i feel like it's really
cold for a long time until like the end when i'm
like oh [ __ ] no it does happen it had to be
cold to get warm yeah and i'm not a very i'm not
i it's weird is i really like their performances
isolated and i like them working together but i
never really felt like that uh strong connection
to their to the romantic chemistry of batman and
catwoman interesting did you feel the chemistry
between gordon and batman that [ __ ] every time
every time every time that might be a question
i jumped ahead yeah oliver heimlin or hamlin
uh what up guys big fan we're a big fan of you
hello what'd you do uh i loved the arkham scene
between batman and riddler uh paul dano killings
oh this is not how i was supposed to go i
i have loved him increasingly each time
though uh paul dano dano apparently is
the pronunciation as per every late night
talk show i've watched him on uh killed it
and made me want more masculist
riddler what were your standout scenes
uh i'll tell you my chunks i imagine there'll
be more specific questions here later other than
the big heroic moment at the end uh there's
a chunk of the film that every time i watch
it i'm like like we did a video now longer that
was called the perfect sequence from spider-man
something like that and there's like a solid
20 minutes of the film and i think that one at
the funeral scene ending on when alfred's build
when when uh bruce thinks alfred's been killed
that whole chunk right there 20 minutes of pure
cinema it's a little bit longer than 20 minutes
uh it felt great it's probably like 40 minutes
really maybe it's the funeral scene every scene
in this movie is like 20 minutes long so it's
like the funeral scene and then it's him in the
police station then it's him on the bat wing and
it's when he flies out then it then they find the
penguin and they go on the dr and then they go on
the car chase and they interrogate penguin yeah
and they find the the what is the deal called
the the our deal the renewal deal renewal deal
with thomas wayne and then he's driving and i love
that shot too when batman is like trying to get to
alfred and then when he yells they don't have they
don't hear him yell yeah yeah and then then he's
and i love the way they played with time there
christopher nolan you know what you're playing
so but yeah i love the way they played with that
time did you get the good time i caught the good
times easter eggs i did not catch it but i saw
it yeah yeah i saw it i thought it was the time
and i just didn't yeah yeah i was
thinking about it just like this
maybe that's what a chain i don't know and then
everybody's like easter egg and i was like oh
i didn't overthink it well and then hearing
that that was the movie that made matt reeves
really want him that was like ah after that movie
everyone wanted robert for me it was the rover man
rover sold me on on our pets the rover watson it's
okay buddy quick cruise of the chat folks want
to see poison ivy i see a ventriloquist killer
croc deacon blackfire bane people want mr freeze
or court of owls in here a lot of mr freezing
cordovals mad hatter some hush hells yeah guys
thank you for chiming in just trying to pay some
love to the main chat as well uh reynaldo torres
torres can't believe i'm saying this but in some
way i loved this more than no way home the batman
made me feel like a kid in the theater watching
a comic come to life the whole theater was an awe
10 out of 10. i'm glad you had such a wonderful
experience you know what i noticed on imax viewing
every time i ever go to the theaters someone whips
out their phone no someone not a single and i had
the perfect seat i managed to snag the perfect
dead center seat that is the top row at universal
ima that's what you want when you're going
to that theater so i get access to everything
i've seen it three times so sometimes there's like
look around it's gonna see what the audience is
reacting like and i couldn't and but the audience
is so quiet and still and not one person whipped
out their phone not once someone had their phone
out at one of my screenings in the first like five
minutes and i was so angry and they were they were
like right here and they literally had their phone
out and they were reading something and typing
they were a two phone [ __ ] and i literally all i
had to say was oi and like everyone in the theater
[ __ ] turned on with yeah it was this really
beautiful like we're all [ __ ] here bro and i've
never seen a universal like we will fight you yeah
and it was similar in the opposite way where
it was like we're all here for the right reason
because i would say no way home is like when
i want to be happy like if i need pure joy i
watch no way home because it is just goodness it's
nostalgia it's actually yeah but like if i want to
[ __ ] vibe i'ma watch the batman now like when
this is on hbo i'm actually april 19th i'm gonna
[ __ ] vibe all the time living in gotham because
this is my favorite like movie atmospherically
this and dune are the most i've ever been like yo
i'm gonna live in this space and that is saying
something for a comic book movie and i think
well the thing is i think it rises above like
good for a comic book movie is that
a pun you know what i mean because uh
did the dark knight rise for you yeah give me
like 20 more minutes i'll be all goofy again okay
so but yeah at the uh but yeah i think in
the for no caffeine today guys apologies so
the um what were we talking about uh dark knight
rises uh batman in the theater phones atmosphere
tone doom well i think i think with a a longer
movie like this is that people really want to be
immersed yeah and because they're like we're here
for three hours it better be fun yeah we were
all righty cool that's uh moises
let me finish a thought i hope my mic's okay uh
moises sombrano batman movie is good but superman
is way better than batman batman run away like a
little girl of doom's day i see batman i seen all
batman in superman's movies you know what that's
poisonous that's fair i don't know what to do
batman is a [ __ ] compared to an alien who gets
power-ups from the sun that's a hilarious cop
batman man and cowboy alien that's great you know
thank you it's good thank you moises uh john so
some of you guys in the chat actually had some uh
people on their phones i'm sorry guys in our imac
screening there was a guy on his phone directly in
front of me oh really i didn't see that yeah yeah
it was it wasn't a ton but he
did pull it up the guy richie
i don't know i tell people he was the most excited
guy he was the one who was screaming like patton
said he's gonna be here and then he lost his
mind when pat and says oh i heard that guy
in the video i watched the video of you i watched
your video after because i wasn't physically there
but uh what annoys me in theaters more now is
the [ __ ] watch everyone's got these goddamn
apple watches and then the thing is no one seems
to know like they're so used to having it they
don't notice their favorite notifications around
light just goes off and then like every 10 minutes
yeah well just cover it just or take it off
and put it i put mine upside down for the
movie yeah please just do that because and i get
it when you're trying to find your seat but you
know like the led phone light just is a beacon
throughout the entire theater it's gonna escalate
now it's like you walk in with a [ __ ]
escalator yeah like a torch josh g you see
the ventriloquist easter egg in the beginning
koi this is the coyote it's not josh g what
are you referring to he's talking about uh i
actually i did not detect any ventriloquist
you know mel gibson i'll be a good friend like
a little puppet like crazy [ __ ] [ __ ] crazy
beard love that justice for melbourne this is
for melbourne is about fantastic milkshakes
and all the super chats of stuff not only have
we name-dropped christielia here in his life oh
[ __ ] we can get louis ck in here let's do it i
think joe roger should be clay face just do it tm
trademark tom maroney uh hi guys i love y'all and
the movie i'm glad we're up to par with the movie
uh knew this movie would be great uh when shapiro
bitched about it after the shitty people we just
mentioned you know i don't even know what he said
but he literally like tweeted out like sorry to
say guys the batman sucked and then just a series
of tweets yeah because a bunch of white dudes are
monsters because a bunch of white dudes are
monsters i got some [ __ ] dude on on tick
tock was like i really enjoyed the batman until it
got all woke and i genuinely and this is the first
time that i genuinely had no idea what he was
referring to so i was like hey man i usually don't
talk to people that unironically use the word woke
but what are you talking about and he was like
well the three black leads were good and a bunch
of white people were bad and i was like are you
saying that politicians generally are corrupt
and white people are generally politicians and
therefore white people are generally [ __ ] uh and
like it was just this weird like i didn't actually
see it as woke because it's just our reality
until we fix [ __ ] movies are gonna have to
reflect it and until we fix it movies are gonna
have to like art has to reflect life so until
white cranky old ass politicians stop [ __ ] with
women and people of color's lives the movies have
to reflect that so [ __ ] everyone that has that
problem with the film because it's real well i
think what was really triggering is the when the
the first time i watched it i was like huh it's
probably gonna be prompted back for people and
then i forgot all about it and the second time i
watched it i was like ah i need to remember that
because it's probably gonna be problematic for
people when they watch it you forget again it was
when when catwoman and then sure enough it just
started happening uh like i saw it all that's on
social media it was even the line about like these
white privileged people and and to me i was like
i'm so into that scene because i'm like she obvi
she knows batman so well she's like you're
probably rich he uses the word choice and
you don't have a choice when you're not rich
yeah like it's such a good line she said white
privilege instead of privileged people but
she added the word what with a strong w woah
why
brady we love you thank you for your generous
contribution today what up guys been waiting for
this as we i loved more than anything how
imperfect batman was because he was still
in his infancy as the world's greatest detective
i wanted to know what your guys thoughts were
i think it creeps up on you because you think
when they say like year two you're like oh he's
more experienced right he's more experienced
than year one he's been out of hurry for a year
but what i thought was interesting was they don't
give you backstory i mean i know there's a prequel
novel and i haven't read the prequel novel nor
do i know the details of what's in it um but i
think for a movie it's really interesting that
they don't give you any real specifics as to
how he kind of was like kind of like how batman
89 is uh where you don't know like how do you
hey get this good like where did he where'd
he learn all this i was smarter in every cop
you know how come now one cop can figure out
one riddle and he's always just like justice
i mean i feel like the lion share the cops
were like wanting it to like they were
dirty so i i like the cops being like i don't give
a [ __ ] about my job like nobody wants something
i really like that they use some of the more
modern detective technology like the contacts
that's from like a scott snyder run of memory
serves which is fairly recent like eight years ago
and they also mixed in the you know the classic
frank miller year one stuff but it all allowed the
intelligence of batman and that's why i think
the riddler was such a great first villain is
you know with with the nolan trilogy you give us
a psychological trilogy you've got um you know
razal ghul and the idea of capitalism being thing
you have to run an underbrush of fire through and
you've got scarecrow with the literal psychology
and then the second one that the line in the sand
between joker and batman and the third and two
phase obviously mirroring the psychology of batman
very very linearly and then bane representing the
the other side of the league of shadows with like
what the city would be under a fascist
rule and like all those things are very
psychological and very um uh socio-economical
but they never once said privileged white
but peop one is more about like you know the the
actual intelligence of the bat like you've got
someone that's making riddles that is literally
the mirror to batman there is no one in this
universe so far quite like the parallel between
riddler and bruce wayne like they're both orphans
they're both using their intelligence to cause
a shift and i really like that they established
the riddler as the first villain because now we've
got a detective series so i agree with what you're
saying but this was much longer than you probably
i think what was cool is that i like when you
captured even like batman begins i like when you
capture the messiness of his first of being uh not
as experienced yeah um because like as a detective
in here you know he is like investigating and
being smarter than a lot of the people around
him but uh when he's a fighter he's just like
the goddamn terminator you know yeah he's just
like let me just march in and get shot you know
let me just get hit a few times it doesn't
matter i'm just going for it whereas i feel
like batman eventually has to be a more strategic
fighter instead of just a direct you know brawler
right away you know not everyone's going to be a
bunch of street folks at a train station at some
point he's got to learn an exposed face man
you can't just walk through hallways all the
holy time that hallway scene in context it is so
sexy it is interesting how like when you watch the
trailers for this movie there are certain moments
in the trailer that are like fist bump moments
and they just they kind of read different
in the actual movie where they're still cool
it's more shocking but you're still like paying
attention yeah you're not like in the movie
you're like you're not cheering you're just like
afraid yeah you're still just watching it yeah
so it's interesting absolutely quentin marcus
where are you on an episode of always sunny
stay rad coy and i were both on it's always
sunny we did great work in season seven we
are a great guy young mac and young dad
it's the phone right that's right we did
and then koi doubled for mcpoyle at
one point yeah you know me and jimmy
simpson just became tweeted for a little while
absolutely he's in the first episode in fact
i think first the first season because i sent
you a bunch of pictures because i was like
middle of a run of that show and i was like greg
cause i didn't know cause he's more humble than me
if i'm in a movie you [ __ ] know it i would love
to go i would love to get back into acting just
to guest star on that show before i could just
do that if i'm like i'm back in acting hey guys
so go ahead and tag me in for season
16. manuel rodriguez other than long
halloween and year one what other
big comic animated references koi
this has a lot of bat cat dna the entire um sunset
sequences that is the lighting and coloring of the
artist clayman who's doing bat cat tom king and
clayman's bat cat that is largely mirroring that
i also think it is a beautiful parallel
to batman ego psychologically there's a
lot of dialogue that's from batman ego either
directly or of psychology and uh there's also
a really good amount of stuff from year zero a
lot of the flooding a lot of those things are
from scott snyder's years you're on as well as the
motorcycles so um those are the big five and those
are actually i made a video in february of what to
read first and then like it was like clockwork of
everything that that ended up popping up which
made me really happy well i think it was also
a hush for sure especially with like batman and
kenneth and then the brother involvement there's
also earth one right there's a little earth one
especially with the martha stuff like martha
arkham like i thought that was a great nod to
flashpoint actually because martha ends up being
crazy in the in the flashpoint storyline thomas
wayne becomes batman because his son is killed
and it leads to thomas wayne being batman
and martha being joker and her going insane
and i thought that was a fun not dumb way
to have that nod of her mental instability
also it sets up a great like batman's a little
[ __ ] crazy because batman's mentally ill
i like that you know sometimes mentally ill um
traits are genetic so i like that martha being in
and out of asylum gave us that little flashpoint
nod an arkham history a reasoning for batman's
craziness like it gave us a lot so you're saying
if you're mentally ill you could become batman
that's what i'm saying that's one of
the reasons saying if you have autism
you can become an accountant hit
man the thing about being on a loss
except for in the movement elif bay rosley
oh you're so generous by the way i've been
looking forward to this movie for the past
two years and watching campia's and your coverage
of everything batman keep up the good work guys
you keep can't be out of this goddamn conversation
you hear me check his dick robert pattinson's
dick the lighting on his dick was more of a
two-face no i'm just joking he's can't be as
my buddy he shouts me out all the time on his
show now i mean we shot him up too look at him
they put me in their spider-man
reaction i was flattered [ __ ] yeah
i've never been quoted on that show and they
won't quote me every year everyone's spending
their super chats with us right now until champion
goes live today is what's happening big sunday
big sunday nerd he goes through the questions
faster than us though the movie uh thank you
nerd collision the movie made me feel as though i
was watching michael keaton's batman for the first
time exciting amazing and breathtaking you know
i did want to save this for a separate video but
he is my favorite batman michael keaton michael
keaton right now i'm going to talk [ __ ] about
this batman you know what i did finish last night
because i couldn't sleep was the founder that
was a good movie i love the founder yeah maybe
you really consider getting back into business
all right i think i got all the wrong lessons i
definitely think you did because everybody's about
corruption but if greg's over here like ah buying
a home and turning into a mcdonald's the uh the
the the yeah i think i think robert pattinson is
definitely probably my like in terms of i i would
not say is my favorite bruce wayne i mean he needs
a little bit more moves for me to call it that but
in terms of batman see the thing is i'd still
be like i think ben affleck's batman could kick
his ass but he's still not but i still think
that robert pattinson's batman is my favorite
rubber pattern is my favorite batman pretty
comfortably the amount he was doing with his
eyes like the amount of empathy sympathy vengeance
compassion rage confusion sadness like there were
so many moments where just robert pattinson's eyes
were a better [ __ ] acting performance i've seen
another [ __ ] i think the thing that rob hansen
has is he's so versatile like if you guys watch
movies like lighthouse or a good time the guy
can carry the guy has he can do dialogue really
[ __ ] well yeah he's an amazing actor and i think
it would be cool to see a natural transgression
versus or transition versus like a studio note
b like people kind of complain about the fact he
wasn't talking make him talk a lot you know but
do it in a natural way where you see him intent
like i would imagine especially if they do end
up introducing quarter owls that he would have to
adopt the bruce wayne personality and put put on
the smiles and stuff because bruce wayne can get
access to [ __ ] that [ __ ] batman probably can't
get access to but as bruce wayne you know you can
meet the right people get into the right groups or
something you know yeah be undercover so i i think
you would have to adapt adopt that and robert
pattinson can't do that like i think i don't
think it would be a challenge it just makes him
cosmopolitan like i actually i was saying people
that want the bruce wayne need to watch cosmopolis
because the batman doesn't need the bruce wayne
yeah he's he can he's amazing actor man he's [ __
] incredible also they call the next one the caped
crusader i think it'd be cool if they changed
the titles like to the batman the kids that way
no one could ever have their own franchise yeah
you could call a different one the batman series
i've always wanted to do uh the dark detective
series like if i made a batman movie get on it
greg start detective what are you doing my current
batman i'm letting other people make battles
my batman movie is just before sunrise
with batman and catwoman uh moises
thank you koi ready for that give me that tagline
romance unmasked oh [ __ ] and by the time they
get to before midnight we have the more elder
looking back on their exploits you can have some
flashbacks of vigilantism yeah they meet up on
a rooftop every night whether it was the beach
or the rooftop yeah oh oh give me that series
oh tom kagame call you we're gonna make this
green light moistus sombrano i am in marvel and
dc how do you do it uh so basically i really i'm
a marvel ndc fan so basically i really don't like
batman i'm a superman and spider-man fan superman
beat batman he's kind of confused but i'm
glad you could get your opinion out there
and i'm just happy you could express yourself
today you know that's uh it takes a lot to
stand up against a whole crowd of people raving
about batman right now yeah this is a bold place
to say it's a bold place man i'm proud of you
dude you are the riddler in this chat but it's
a safe space nonetheless thank you dark jedi
knight do you think that the sequel will give
us the court of owls i want to see the talons
done right also i need to see the catwoman come
back i think catwoman's definitely coming back i
want a solo movie though first man yeah i really
want to see her in bloodhaven and like you know
hinting at the world they're gonna give night
night wing and also like i wanted to settle into
the alley town oh robin i think we can take some
time that orphan the the the mayor's kids gonna be
yeah that could have crowbar written all over him
dude i think i think it works it could work yeah
i think it could work because there was definitely
a connection to both bruce wayne bruce wayne and
batman and he was dressed in red the first time
we see him that's true dressed as a ninja man
i i want shadows that's right he's the red hood
if this was a marvel movie you know there'd
being 18 videos about like he had a presentation
as a marvel fan he had a red hood on uh but i do
think uh the court of alas and the talons be a
really great escalation i would personally set
that up for the third movie and i would have a
little bit more i want the court of owls to be
just as it was in the comics this big reveal of
oh my god gotham yeah and i feel like if you set
some eggs easter in the next film uh to hatch in
the third would be the way to do it so i'd love
that person some damn good egg metaphor dialogue
i actually used a comma in verbal
you hear that little looking
crack that egg open and find out that they've been
spilling their yolk all over gotham city you know
it's no yolk man so the uh a-plus part of me
does wonder like what if they fed ridler some
information like how did ridley how did that
how did he know the details of the renewal oh
yeah what was his uh well he's a he they said
he's a forensic accountant which means he goes
through all the numbers and all those but he
can find out all those details he's also a
professional video editor too yeah he outsources
that to one of his followers does anyone know how
don't worry about it yeah did we
i thought there was something to
follow up on there talon quarterbacks the
annoying renter hey guys what's the the 500
mexican oh thank you so much hey guys
there's a mexican with five hundred dollars
and i just gotta know something about the batman
what if the next movie uses in no man's land thank
you by the way what if the next movie uses a no
man's land approach to level up the rogues to
comic book level introduce mr freeze via a heart
of ice storyline intro the court of owls maybe
tease the joker for a third entry in reeves
we trust literally what i want like you just
described everything i want i'm on joker later
and i want mr freeze next i want a long form quote
yes i agree with you the annoying rancher well
matt reeves said something that uh rare that
we just learned yesterday was that a writ there
was a scene that would bear which i think if this
scene was in the movie everything all right oh i
think oh i think the camera's gonna cut guys i'm
just gonna hit record here really quick and
then i'm gonna stop recording b-roll for us
later in the future when i'm like oh [ __ ] we
need to expand out this take or some dumb joke all
right so the um yeah i think what he was saying
was that originally they had a scene where batman
goes to the joker to ask for help it's kind of
like a clarice and hannibal moment for him which
i think would be really cool since there are
signs of the lamb's inspirations in this film
and i i actually think if that scene was in
this movie that others the other scene would
have worked way better not been like they just
tacked this on for sequel purposes you know it
actually would have worked uh a lot stronger and i
think actually having joker in there like kind of
getting to know i like the idea of building up the
way how they did penguin yeah penguin's like the
prime example here where he's penguin's not that
much screen time but he still feels like he had a
a an impact because this movie's three hours so in
like a two hour movie would feel like he was only
there for 10 minutes yeah in a three hour movie
you can get him there for like 30 minutes and it
feels like he's got a decent amount of screen
time right and i think that's what you should
do with some of your other villains here as you're
building them up when you got you got the penguin
show you've also got this apparently like arkham
slash police show i thought it was three shows
apparently it's two shows because the arkham cop
show and personally as someone who who sees most
of our television as propaganda i'm really excited
to see a arkham show mirroring the two mad houses
of gotham you've got the corrupt cops and the
insane that are legally declared insane and people
just described to be cops like i think that'd be a
really interesting dichotomy of show um so i think
that's how you introduce so many villains and give
them the long form take like you did with penguin
letting them have little little sins sprinkled
without to build that arkham universe out
um so yeah i love this approach and i do think
the joker um that extra scene will really help
the film because one of the only scenes i don't
like is a joker scene it's not barry's fault it's
just it felt like it was studio note yeah felt
like well you gotta at least keep this one see
yeah yeah you hired mary cogan yeah well you could
have just really cut to the riddler devastated
yeah and just dealing with that and it could just
end it there especially with how moody it is like
watching him feel like a failure yeah you know
and and watching yeah that be like the sort of
modus like the the inspiration for him to come
back bigger and better because i'm sure i i prefer
the juxtaposition there where in a lot of ways
riddler did win like in more ways than one riddler
destroyed gotham he destroyed gotham yeah and now
he's smart and the whole thing they just followed
his path even when they thought they were a step
ahead of him yeah they were all he was always
ahead and then won like riddler won this movie
yeah but these but with the way but riddler won
yet riddler feels like he lost because he didn't
get the batman and so i i would love i wish you
just ended on that juxtaposition with the two yeah
and i think that would have been more poignant
lily aguilera hey lily hello real reject
and coy that's that's greg and coy
yeah you don't mention you rejects and yeah
john john and john and tech monkey what was the
one scene that left you speechless mine was the
scene with batman and riddler love all you guys
first of all i want to acknowledge that there
is only one scene with batman and ridler and
that's cool i really like that you you listed this
because when you look at the movie you're like oh
yeah batman fighting riddler there's no physical
fight because he's a mental villain which i really
enjoyed that that not comic book take and that
scene was incredible uh for me it was i cannot get
over the first introduction of the batmobile in
this universe like when they when they cut to that
car and it just turns on like a demon and like
that entire chase sequence we've seen a thousand
chase sequences that movie it uses this really
simple but obvious and honest and great technique
of penguin is usually shot over the shoulder so
you feel like you're being pursued by batman so
you get the paranoia of the penguin you also get
some great reaction shots you get to feel the fear
of the batman but then with batman you're usually
behind the car shot so you feel like you're the
one pursuing so you you subconsciously feel like
you are batman in those shots and then you feel
like you're being chased when you're penguin so
that car chase reinvents a very obvious choice
but does it in a comic book cinema and and that
plus the roar of the batmobile like that whole
sequence had me [ __ ] hard yeah it was really
uncomfortable sitting next to me i know i was like
bro bro look at this [ __ ] batmobile that's what
i call them now let's rev this engine barracuda
give me one sec guys i think i think i was
like this this is an odd moment i think to
pull but for whatever reason i i was left kind
of speechless after the moment where he right
as gordon pulls him off that guy in the catwalk
when he injects himself with the adrenaline and
he's just unleashing all of the pain and rage and
even catwoman is like whoa dude that you trying
to calm me down and even though that's not like
the biggest most picturesque moment in the movie
that was a moment where when he turns around
and he's got that wild look on his face like
he could have decked gordon if you didn't have
that one little ounce of restraint like that that
left me pretty speechless in the moment i got
a confession to make about that scene you don't
like that scene i actually love that scene it's
one of my favorites but when he turns around as i
i always think of the batman
from how it should have ended
right now i'll still be
speechless for other reasons
oh he's so good because i'm batman it's like a mix
of will or net and how it should have been it is
pretty much so we'll earn it we are not caught up
we're not no we're about to refresh our friends
go to the stream yeah pull up the live chat
here on the phone uh really quick uh hey in
the chat in the live chat somebody uh victor
manav wants to know what's your favorite riddle
what's your favorite did you have a favorite
riddle out of the movie uh out of the different
riddler rhythms like the first one he lied
still is pretty great like because it's just
the the the layers in the answers you know
what i've seen it three times and it's my
favorite one and i remember some of the other
ones too they're not coming to mind right now
that is a good first clever because i like the
layers of eli still like even after death and also
he's physically still like i like a good pun i
like a good pun riddles that one's my favorite you
know what's weird this isn't good it's not really
a riddle but for whatever reason see you in hell
really uh like unfolded in my mind because i was
like that means so many things i see you right now
in hell beholding what's happened to alfred
i will see you in hell when i am in prison
yeah i also see you in hell as the city but like
there's a lot of people think that's bane venom
yeah venom yeah the early stages for it yeah i i
could see that but i also don't know how much bane
would work in this yet so i don't know if they
literally work of course darth knight rises you
can work here i love bane i just want him smarter
than that dark knight rises bane is not bane from
the cops no no no but i think it i i think you
just need a smarter than bruce bane and i think
you you could get there bruce bane uh i think one
more movie until till dane i'm going to mexico
pandemic jones thank you buddy good to see you
absolutely yeah thank you pandemic uh yeah i
can't wait for the pitch meetings i was just
looking at stuff from you guys chat i absolutely
loved this movie the cinematography and music was
amazing my favorite sequences were the car chase
gill bomb and riddler talking to batman in prison
also loved that they focus on the detective batman
what were your favorite mementos well i already
say my favorite sequence so what would you say
when you re-watch this what are you like waiting
for what i'd love i really love like i think if i
had to nail down like a see a scene that i just
love it is it is the whole thing at the police
station there's something about that the way
the way gordon and him are talking and he's just
like doing this downstairs yeah when the cops like
i'll get you a charge for assaulting officer three
you can't even count yeah i also
love like his moonlighting as a cub
and i love that little smile he get that when
batman smiles that little i think you got that
jawline there yeah yeah there's like something
there's something like so cool about that because
he never smiles and he does it's awesome i caught
the most smiles on the third viewing yeah there
was someone said he never smiles i'm like he does
they're just very subtle yeah uh i think the the
fight between catwoman and batman when he like
drops down and pretty good at that and like it's
just so catwoman like the way she's breaking into
that like all of her physicality and the way they
fight just feels so like [ __ ] sexy like i love
the bat in the cat so that that sequence really
worked for me good call i'm gonna give some love
to alfred and bruce in the hospital quality acting
cause uh yeah like just the way that i almost like
the third time i was just sitting there going just
tell him you love him bruce just tell me to say i
love you i know he's not gonna but i want him to
real bad and yeah for whatever reason here in this
moment because you we've talked about so many of
the other iconic wonderful beautiful moments and
uh aside from like the opening of the movie at
the very ending of the movie that's that's another
one that certainly stands out i do i really like
the choice of bruce in this movie a lot uh i do
think though i have a hard time there's this like
dark night of the soul moment uh after alfred
dies and he's learning the truth about his folks
that's what bruce wayne calls his parents this
is my folks so he's learning the truth about
his parents and he seems like all devastated
after he talks to carmine falcone i have a hard
time feeling like i i think broad path is doing
a great job acting but as a viewer i don't really
feel the devastation with him or for him because
like i don't this movie does no flashbacks and
he doesn't do any talking at all about you know
his relationship with thomas wayne so really all
i have to work off of is you know my prior
knowledge of batman moving into this movie
so it's weird because in that scene that you're
talking about i don't really connect with bruce
but i reconnect the i connect so much with alfred
and i and like he brings me to tears in that scene
like he's such a it's such a uh such a great
moment for him when you're you're seeing
how much this guy's sacrificing how he just
feels like he sucks up doing what he's doing
and now he has this feeling of you know like the
last thing he'd want is for bruce to look down
on his parents when they sacrificed everything for
him and they and probably cost their lives because
he was trying to protect them you know so i love
alfred's perform i love annie circus performance
in that moment but i do feel like i could
have used like one thing of him talking about
you know his parents in some way we don't
need to see the pearls and the alleyway
shot or anything like that i'm glad there were no
flashbacks though because i like that i like that
like goes in the mansion and that whole like
super emo moment when he goes into like the way
uh his parents like i'm not really for so every
time i watch it i don't really feel much when
i'm watching it all right but yeah i yeah
also shouts out to when bruce shows up to uh
when bruce himself shows up to the club oh that's
so great and that one-two punch of uh like because
he does like a haymaker uppercut combo and drops
that dude yeah but i like the transition when he's
going through the crowd or everyone's just looking
at him and he doesn't give a [ __ ] he's just wet
and this imposing thing and then he goes to the
black and the red flashing no he's at the dancing
hello yeah well that but also when he shows up
to talk yeah to karma when he just shows up and
he's like you know who i am and tweedledee and
tweedledum are like yeah i know who you are yeah
dude also tweedledeems feel dumb shout out i love
that we got like a solid carver twins john daniel
there's a moment early on where bruce gets out
of his car at pete's funeral and the and sneers
at the paparazzi and i'm convinced that
pattinson did that instinctively i mean
[ __ ] the paparazzi yeah [ __ ] the paps bruh
our pat says [ __ ] that did he really sneeze
i think what some people want is um bad bruce
wayne to be just so into the alter ego personality
that it affects his batman work like he he's
just like parties way too much batman he's
i need electrolytes
hi all greg would your cats get along with zoe
kravitz's catwoman good question and what did
y'all think of the catwoman compared to the others
have uh a good day it is the most batman year
one ever our cats would get along with cat one
cause cats are feelers more than anything else
and um just like all animals really i think boy
cats especially are just all about feeling and
yeah absolutely uh her catwoman i think i i still
you know it's been i don't
want to know if it's nostalgia
i think it's still michelle pfeiffer for me
it's hard to beat hello there michelle pfeiffer
could only exist in the tim burton universe and
zoe could only exist in this universe
so it's really hard for me because
especially compare compare make the choice make
the choice no but like i think out of anyone next
to batman like catwoman is a product of gotham
right so i feel like the manic insane energy of
michelle pfeiffer is the most like cinematic
and big and bold cell so our first also that
outfit like there's so many things that make that
iconic but that would only work at the cranked up
to not even 11 but 14 gotham that is tim burton's
universe so i think the reason people might like
not like this one as much as that one one first
introduction but also she has to be more real she
has to be more grounded she has to operate both as
selena and catwoman she has her mask off more than
anyone so i think the i thought zoe kravitz's
backstory was that she died but cats brought
her back oh yeah no no that was the cutscene that
was the joker the joker has to explain the batman
he's like you know your girlfriend got eaten
by cats um but no that died so i feel like zoe
kravitz like she had to do a more subdued thing so
i loved this catwoman personally but i also can't
separate my insatiable crush on zoe kravitz so she
is she's in my phone background for you this movie
brought me around to her yeah yeah i absolutely
adored her performance in this movie whenever
john saw her before he'd always be like [ __ ]
some correctness no it's the thing it's it's one
of the every now and again an actor arrives skips
fury road scenes he's like [ __ ] no no no no no
no it's it's it's that thing like i had a similar
thing with chalamet and and and i'm still bridging
that gap to a degree where i'm like you're
perfectly fine i i think you're good but i just
don't connect with you for some reason have you
seen them [ __ ] a peach i haven't and i wonder
i wonder if that's what changes you once
you see them actually funny enough french
dispatch is the movie i've liked him in the
most so far aside from dune because dune he's
like perfectly cast for that um but yes this one
this movie totally endeared me to zooey kravitz
anyhow certainly interrupted that but yeah so i
think zoe kravitz's like oh check out kimmy too
kimmy's really good see the subway's new movie
yeah i've been uh i've been hearing about that
bubblegum thank you for asking your job
today is to give the right look so that
way these two know like you know we're gonna be
here forever and i'm trying not to avoid that
before you guys are crashing and i'm
like see that that was interesting
curtis mason i just finally saw the batman last
night with my dad i am so glad i saw this in
theaters this was my first dc film watched in
theaters since man of steel what a spectacular
first one says man of steel good one a lot of
dc movies you were like [ __ ] that opted out
what a spectacular experience and i loved the
movie so much uh druid as joker is gonna be dope
so first of all curtis mason is one of my patrons
he's an exceptional human being second of all
i don't know how much more druid as joker we're
gonna get i have a feeling it might not be
a bit until the third one uh and thirdly uh
bird of birds of prey is pretty dope man bird's
parade's uh worth checking up i like bob the bop
is a bop ah i'm glad you like me i'm glad you're
with me greg sitting here like man the energy
no man no no eventually you guys will crash and
then i'm gonna yeah an hour three of these when
i step in and go it's my turn i reserve i i i've
learned in these streams because before when we
do these streams i would be so high so up there
and then i realized i gotta take a breather yeah
because we might be here a while and i hate when
we're like i'm just dead sometimes i facetime in
and i've already left i am crashed at all times
thanks curtis pattinson hates being called
our pat's coy yeah yeah [ __ ] the disrespect
[ __ ] i love it i loved the movie and saw it
twice i do appreciate you coy calling out the
criticisms that just aren't fair i'm intrigued
by the batman joker deleted scene after uh set
after the commissioner's death yeah this movie's
perfect there's nothing wrong with this movie
every moment is perfect there's nothing wrong
with it we got more from dan v uh the brother
revealing joker in november was disappointing uh
wish i didn't know going in hush is going to uh
hush is being set up and reeves said he wants to
use him people claiming he only called himself
vengeance are wrong he says this could be the end
of the batman to gordon i feel like that detail
is left with a bit of ambiguity i feel like he is
toying with being called vengeance but also aware
that everyone calls him the batman and is probably
conscientious enough to know that you don't
always choose your nickname i also like the idea
that like he sees himself as a force of nature
until he acknowledges he has to be a symbol like
the batman symbol metaphor is the entire dark
knight trilogy and the moment in the movie
where the the riddler like you know lackey
says i'm vengeance is him realizing
his symbol's been stolen and how that
is a negative and how vengeance isn't always a
positive like beautiful way to do the entire nolan
trilogy like summarized in a moment but i do think
him acknowledging the batman as a symbol is going
to be a really great arc in a different way in
this universe because of that like the disparity
you're talking about i'm just saying this bruce
wayne better be doing loads of cocaine though lots
of below appearances very important that's
what's most important dan v again and alfred's
like you better keep up appearances he's like
get the hookers alfred call my dealer outfit
he talks to alfred in the bathroom wait associates
are coming here where are my benzos out there
now got an equation for him to just
get so reactionary the way wb can be
crawling on his face to the
batmobile they just realized that
they call it the bruce yeah they're just cg
that should be that should be the sequel is
him struggling to balance his party life addiction
this is way harder this is way harder than crime
i just love the juice and then people are going to
be like bruce wayne was never this much of a party
yeah too much playable so much public personality
he wouldn't buy the entire russian opera boat damn
what happened oh he did that's right yeah with the
ballerinas and everything good because that way
he stole aaron aircraft date night but he also
had an alibi double bruce wayne double the fun
double bruce dan v two more from danvy now i don't
want joker in the sequel since it still feels
early dan we're on the same page reeves explained
his take on the joker where he's not joker yet and
he's and uh he has a smiling condition different
from joaquin phoenix's laughing condition but
batman put him in prison already is interesting
i'm looking forward to the deleted scene and then
dan goes on to say the entire cast crushed
it i said it after good time that pattinson
could be batman i said i wanted paul dayno as
the riddler for years remember when jonah hill
was cast as riddler but dropped out due to money
dano then being cast made my day he nailed it i
remember the jonah hill thing that'd be really
interesting now having seen the film because i
think he would have leaned more into the online
persona i think we would have seen a bit more
of that like trolling like leaning into like
i'm what's black and white it dead all over
yeah because like jonah's an incredible actor i
just think that would have been more of an element
to it because paul dano's got that operatic
literally in this case big theatricality
that that philip seymour hoffman acting whereas
jonah hill has a more subdued snark yeah flev
flavius doran hi guys i was really impressed by
the film being a more detective story and all
my mistake was that i watched it at 11 00 p.m 11
p.m screening when i uh was a jockey highlighted
yes sir when i was very tired so my enjoyment
was affected uh by it hope to watch it again
at a decent hour after i have had time to die
i'm out at 2 a.m i don't i don't blame you like
for a movie i'm sorry no man do your thing just
pee in the chair when uh for what does that mean
for a movie like that to be three hours long and
start at 11 o'clock and especially when it's your
first time where you're truly not prepared for the
kind of pacing it is i think that's i think that's
like the main thing is that i think the pacing
is great at the same time i don't think a lot
of people are properly prepped for the pacing
of the movie absolutely the movie the trailers
leave a different impression as if that like the
pacing will be much quicker yeah and there will
be a lot more like crazy picturesque actions
i could see if you go in tired you could fall
asleep to this movie yeah and i wouldn't be like
you suck you don't like movies enough bang bang
for you yeah i'd be like no i get it i i'd fall
asleep yeah i totally understand although it's
maybe it's maybe it's the benefit of the times in
which we have seen it is every time we've seen it
i think both of us have been pretty sleep deprived
and luckily not yet i've yet to fall asleep during
the batman so uh that's the path that's the
power of quality cinema monkey in the chat danny
devito or colin farrell who did it better danny
devito did it more i think we'll need to see uh
what else colin farrell grows into well i don't
think it's a fair comparison because like penguin
the the burden verse is so fantastical it's like
so fantastical like jack nicholson falls into a
vat of toxic chemicals it comes out with perfect
clown makeup you know on his face and then has
to paint his face normally yeah yeah penguin who
like was raised with penguins and it was like a
penguin yeah and yeah he's like way more of like a
creature yeah and catwoman was resurrected by cats
mm-hmm you know and cat zombies so like it's
it's silly it's much sillier uh so i don't think
like they're so different whereas i think penguin
and this one is more uh al capone versus danny
devito's which is like human penguin and i really
adore them both for being able to bring such a
natural quality to such an outlandish character
both times like danny devito like you forget
you think of dan devito and you think of
like it's always sunny and stuff like that
but you forget like oh he could really act and
like really sell an outlandish character like that
and then and then colin farrell on the other end
is like chameleon total transformation you know
oh yeah thanks any sign any time leaving the space
for koi for just tuning in yeah pandemic jones
pdj did you guys have any nitpicks with the movie
yeah i felt like the bat and the catwoman romance
came out of nowhere unexpected yes love them
together though lol what did you guys think
of everyone's portrayal more specifically
pattinson is batman i think he's my fave
i i think that we need some a little bit of more
time with his bruce wayne for me to really narrow
it down because i do think it's a part of batman
that he has to eventually do the dual personality
like i think it's a part of his character
um but in terms of a nitpick my only real
nitpick is when he's uh doing the back
wing suit i think that is some pretty awful
cgi it looks like daddy's home
when mark wahlberg is skateboarding
they're like bobble heads that like looks like
a kind of like we attached his head on some
it looks like a green screen thing like i could go
to some event and they could put my head on top of
his head or something like that i don't think that
that wing suit looks that good weirdly on imax
it looks all right yeah yeah because you're like
overwhelmed yeah and people applaud it after that
yeah the first time i heard the applause yeah
first yeah but when we saw it the first time yeah
oh i was like oh that is not look good yeah
well and yeah the nature of the shot itself
doesn't help whatever cg embellishments they
had to do because it's already kind of a funky
looking thing when you're locked on his head
and his body is moving independently of that
yeah it looks sick and that's how it looks in real
life when you do one of those headlock games but
with the movie being so grounded it was like what
a strange turn yeah uh my only nitpick is the uh i
think the joker scene should have been post credit
i have a nitpick no you just keep you on all right
i'm doing a live stream i got
a couple small nitpicks one
uh when did he go back and swim around for
his knife oh thanks man uh because he clearly
dropped it when he fell off the cable all right
he's got a couple probably transferred to uh
transfer the 50 000 and uh other nitpick
and it's not really he's finally paying
nitpick oh yeah koi is the decade they find
it really hard to get before tourist studios
you hear me [ __ ] hear me
this moment in the livestream i'm gonna
need to find this moment again the nip
someone tell us what time stand it's very lucky
that we go over the scene we should we should
play john campio's live stream let's get it
yeah here let's go to cambia right now
i noticed whilst watching the movie this time
it's very lucky that bruce doesn't have to deal
with any of the cops when the explosion
happens at wayne tower because he's at
every crime scene anywhere there's a to the batman
letter he is summoned and asked to show up in the
movie very conscientiously glosses entirely past
the possibility of that uh and i was sitting there
thinking but what if they shine the bat signal
or like you know is this the one time batman's
not gonna show up bro gordon's gonna be like
what gives dude why didn't they try to take
off his mask way earlier yeah too yeah yeah they
take him and take it off and probably yeah yeah
they're mutter about it they're like man never
mind that's it how do we get it off he should
have had a little zappy thing like a dark knight i
always thought that was clever in dark knight yeah
yeah i think that was clever
um i think on the wall
even though they leave it ambiguous of like
does ridler actually know he's batman or not
there's enough where he at least contemplated it
on it was enough to be on the wall where batman
was like oh [ __ ] he knows i'm persuaded yeah you
know that's why he goes to arkham hospital like
that and he's pretty much saying he's goodbye to
gordon in that scene he's like you're a good cop
you know like saying his goodbye he's like this
is the time for the batman to end like he's
he's accepted it he's looking at the wall going
[ __ ] river figured it out also the idea that no
cop was like those chins yeah like right next
to each other but that's also a batman nippy
bruce uh campbell bruce wayne flem doran i was
impressed by all performances but i felt in
a batman film batman was the least outstanding
every secondary character played great but bruce
being the lead i expected a different standard and
it didn't hit for me not to say that he was bad
i think the batman performed great and i think
bruce we talked about the top of this wasn't
wasn't a lead yet so like the batman i think
was a very intentional title personally the
last like hour of this movie you don't see bruce
after he leaves the hospital with alfred i think
it's great he's just only in the batsuit yeah
well and yeah like i can absolutely uh respect
your opinion but i do i do feel like uh there is
something no no you guys are gonna live in the
dark with us for a while now i was born welcome to
the darkness moulded by it i'm a [ __ ] i didn't
see the camera until i was a man uh but yeah i do
it does seem like this is the batman movie where
the forefront of the conversation and the debate
is batman before we get to the other characters in
most conversations i've had and that seems
unique to me even if it's about people not
necessarily loving him as much i feel like there
is something to be said for the fact that it's at
least interesting and distinct enough that it is
often among the first things people mention rather
than it being the villains and then well i think
that's a full arc people keep saying he doesn't
have an arc in this movie no i think what people
are missing is that bruce wayne doesn't really
have an ark it's batman who has an arc that's
kind of the point of like it ends on batman
but and it also ends with he's batman so bruce
would also have the same epiphany like my issue
bruce doesn't have an ark i'm like guys
bruce is doing the voiceover guys spoiler
bruce wayne is back yeah so when the voiceover
happens that's bruce having the same identity
the arc happens through his identity as batman
and i think that's great i think that's beautiful
you don't see that usually it's you know we've
seen the [ __ ] dark knight movies you'd say
give some goddamn monologue right what the theme
is in the lesson and it's usually i am iron
man not i am robert downey jr i am tony stark
like yeah we've seen the other you know marwan
what was your favorite scene in the movie mine
personally was the whole fear as a tool opening
you see that whole thing about that opening
of why i love it is i i personally feel like
the did i ever say this in the stream about
the opening we talked about the bookends but
we didn't talk about just the opening i think
i've said that i think this is the best 15 to
20 minutes of any batman movie and like the first
thing that pops into mind is better than the dark
knight i think that is a great joker prologue um
i think it's a perfect that that pro i think it's
brilliant even though there's like some nitpicks
like you mean no one's gonna know the box was
coming it had no one crashed through this big
ass making like one dusty bus one dusty bus but
but i don't ever think about that funny enough
when i'm watching it but the but in this like
they said the way they set up the riddler the
parallels of the intro of the actual visual
introductions of seeing riddler and seeing batman
and also the way they introduce batman in here
more than just pulling straight from long
halloween it just feels like pure batman
like my favorite moment in that whole thing is
when they're talking about the shadows and then
you're cutting to the criminals and they just
like it's like that signals up that feeling that
we have with horror when you're like is that
is that there when he says i am in the shadows
i buy it yeah no they're like panicking infinity
and he's not even there but they just think he's
there and that's how scared they are of him
and it's a great way to set him up and so i
and that's why it's like you start off that movie
where he's in the dark and then it ends where he's
like in the in the light with the people you know
yeah it's beautiful it's a [ __ ] arc what i love
i loved it in the prologue too he refers to it
to the crime and criminals just as the element
yeah and at the end he clarifies criminal element
but i just love that phrasing let's keep going all
right flavius fled more flev uh all right cool
we'll be good here yeah flavin another marwan
uh my favorite dc villain is deathstroke because
of arrow and titans and so i love the coin
and so i would love to see him in the next film
i don't know how much a direction he and batman
actually had in the comics but i just want to see
a proper portrayal of the big screen you know i
think you guys see that man's genitals in the show
spartacus the one who plays deathstroke and arrow
oh dude and there's a comic where you see batman's
dick so we can get them both naked dicks people
want an r-rated batman so bad that's how you get
there yeah that's how you do it just hit that
back dick to have replay value this video and now
it's not going to no it doesn't look like you're
we've done shot ourselves goddamn foot here
people uh deathstroke's a great character
and they were going to do deathstroke
as the main villain in the batfleck one
uh i do think that inevitably that
that stuff will come to light because
well i i do think it's inevitable
because if you notice a lot of these
studios if they develop a script to a point
they're gonna use some of that later so
i do think with the stuff coming out of the
snyder verse that they're keeping they will be
a death troop that would piss off so many people
but it's coming but it wouldn't piss off marwan
you know what they should do they should
get ben affleck to direct it right yeah
that guy looks like bulked up marwan what is your
favorite scene in the movie and what are your uh
what are your complaints my personal favorite
scene is the whole fear is a tool monologue
my only comment is that uh no cop noticed that
there was a connection between bruce wayne and
batman on the wall that was one of my nitpicks too
and i also do feel like the cops are like pretty
apathetic like they don't really care um except
except martinez i mean martinez which hey martinez
i love you that's a favorite scene uh batman's
walking through the cops and he's like a foot
taller everybody and he's just so intimidating and
martinez puts his hand yeah like that's a favorite
scene well and also too the book end then when
he when it's just the two of them in riddler's
apartment he's finally like all right okay i'll
try and work with you yeah martinez's arc is great
that is such an enjoyable scene because batman
does nothing he just left martinez just lets
him oh you know it's a tool for tucker when you
first see that scene it seems like he's annoyed
with him yeah yeah he's like put in the light i'm
like stop talking to me again actually a good tip
did that come from you i grew up rich i don't
have carpet i don't know how to install it carpet
someone puts this in you want to strap
a rocket onto a barracuda let's do this
and i do like when they reveal
the carpet how it looks awkwardly
placed yeah you're like there is
something strange about this carpet like
carpet bright green yeah it's good absolute vodka
i'm just gonna catch us up to the super chats
somebody a monkey in the chat asked us but you
didn't get to weigh in danny devito or colin
farrell who did it bitter colin farrell for me
uh i love danny devito's take because it is so
otherworldly and so big but there is a lot of
in discrepancies between like i'm running for
politics because i want to no i don't and yes this
is there's a lot of like story elements that have
to happen so if you guys hit the like button
before i forget please stop no i was answering
can you hit the like button and see if i
interrupt you it sounds like it's an important
thing like excuse me emergency hit the
like button all right koi now please
danny devito felt like he was having to do things
for the sake of the story whereas colin farrell
felt like he led the story so i like colin
farrell's take i also like a more grounded
take on the batman so for me it's colin farrell
pretty comfortably he stole every scene he was
in and this is a movie of powerhouse actors
so brianna says in the chat about apparently
batman doesn't understand spanish i believe
that i am going to have a confession here
i did not realize until it was pointed out to me
that when he goes on to the website i was like
oh url yeah oh you didn't catch that i was like
yeah how does he know to go on the website like
everyone i talked to who knows that yeah i love
that because that has a flow that's completely
gone over my head every single time it's the only
thing that said slowly like in that whole sequence
u r l greg's like w w w because i just think of
it i don't think of the letter u that's why it's
such a good word i know yeah i know it's i get
it uh but it's not the world's greatest decision
i was like i could pick up
on all the character pathos
and read into that visual complexities but
then we say something like url like how did
he know to go to that website hacker man one
and uh vaguely tangentially on topic i just
adore that penguin is like you guys don't speak
spanish i'm like do you speak spanish spaniel
like the guy that's going to be dealing with every
person is going to know more than the guy that's
only dealt with the elite i love that the penguin
is like guys i speak 17 languages yeah there yeah
that's something the penguin's smart yeah a lot
of people need to remember that because these
are the that's part of penguin's character you
don't become a crime boss accidentally you look
at him and you laugh him off you think he's a
joke that's the big part of penguin yeah buddy
but he's actually a really smart guy i i really
love the portrayal on the gotham show i think it's
a very underrated show even people who don't like
i've seen second season no i just i love that the
amount of times gotham's come up in the last
month of my life versus the other five years
i've seen all of you i've seen all of gotham i
think gotham's i i think uh especially the second
season it really finds a stride really strong but
that's another reason i think colin farrell over
danny devito answered that question further is
the intelligence of penguin is beautifully done
with colin farrell yeah david gandy thank you
for the moment of silence friend david thank you
thank you darling david david's the best miguel
martinez love you david we love you indefinitely
uh miguel martinez batman or spider-man what
comic book movie did you guys enjoy the most
the movie i'd want to make is batman sure yes
i put it like that if i was to watch these two
movies i'd go which one feels like a filmmaker's
movie and one that i'd be like oh i want to
make a movie like that it's batman spider-man is
obviously probably much easier to rewatch and much
more of a crowd pleaser and it's more easter eggs
but at the same time i mean i don't want to fully
say this because it still has that special thing
of the three of them coming okay let's like this
i feel like we're going to get more movies with
tommy mcguire and andrew garfield teamed up
if it with tom holland right yeah we're gonna
it's gonna be it's gonna happen and then by
that point it's like now when you see the avengers
together you're like yeah it's just the thing let
them go versus like the first time you've seen
them where you're like they're spinning around
six characters i love yeah you can put movies
together that impact is gonna like really go down
once we're like oh they're doing it all once
we're used to it yeah once the spider-verse movie
happens it's inevitable yes where and while i do
think that's a fantastic movie um this one is more
it's special in a very different way and
it sucks that i instantly knew people will
compare them and it doesn't help that the same
composer did the score for both these moves
does not get enough credit how do you pronounce
it john gichino i believe it's jacquino i think
his is twitter yeah the fact that the fact
that michael j michael in fact the mg mgk mgk
batman score the fact that he is an alpha he has
an omega like he did both of these scores for the
like two sensational combo movies they're two very
different films it's really impressive man and the
energy of both is reflected in the score yeah the
energy of spider-man is so different than this and
like three months apart uh i i don't think i
can honestly compare them like i know that the
expression apples and oranges is a common
one but like this to me is like do i want
a burger or do i want a pizza do i want a
a savory steak or do i want a salad like
you don't you don't go for them for the same
purpose so honestly they're both a's and they're
both exceptional in their field but their fields
are so different that i i cannot say ones about
the other person and that's saying a lot because
i love spider-man pretty heavy so like for batman
to be as good as just insane but they're both
considered comp movies so they must be comparable
there are ends of the spectrum for me they're two
polar sides because they're both like superlatives
in their own way but you know batman is very
meticulous very like tightly crafted whereas
spider-man is pretty loose with its details and
its circumstances but it really nails the heart
and the fun whereas the batman nails the grit
and the tone and and the deeper themes and
all that stuff like like they're great
polar ends of the spectrum i feel like
can you pin adrian a's comment
i was gonna point that out yeah
yes uh uh uh why does greg look like rasputin
from the king's man in the thumbnail uh does that
have curly hair not so good yeah what and also
shouts out to the man gareth hood just popping
up in the chat i haven't seen you in ages my dude
we will get to your super chat 3 000 people were
able to vote which character was your favorite
yeah wear them like where are the like buttons
we need this to have replay value
and that's how you get it i think
i don't understand youtube all righty jones
lots of code up in a whopper one virus effects
follow him on the gram he makes cool prosthetics
and and uh special effects gags and stuff among
other things good artists as well we got a couple
of his paintings up on the wall batman should vape
bat vape never leave the cave without it and
dude how badass would he look with just the
just a fatty cloud coming that scene with
the fire extinguisher wasn't actually it was
vape look at this because dakota jones made that
look at that speaking of deathstroke deathstroke
and we also got homelander up there too
boom hey guys love seeing you all again
the last scene come back here and grab pictures
off the wall do it grab our displays grab
everything uh oh you guys got that displayed
sponsored yeah shouts out to this display
find a recent video go in the description and save
yourself 23 percent on one or two displays or 27
on three or more with our uh special link oh
you got a baby oh yeah they only got one of
those big ones yet they send you the big ones
when you're sponsored well excuse me display
you got my number i buy from you monthly i bought
one yeah on my own i have 38 because they're cool
wow i have a lot of displays and i have an eight
places i rotate them through so my background's
always different depending on what i'm
talking about i just put up my tupac my
eminem next to my batman once i get a different
sponsor i'm taking them damn display stamina
the last scene in between you you do
look like randy from christmas card
uh with the blimp uh the last scene
between alfred and bruce had me in
tr's and the car the [ __ ] car was beautiful also
the way the villains were portrayed as top notch
i couldn't agree more yeah i'm really
getting like a comfort situation at least
do you need anything else over there you want
some ear muffs a little you want a scarf or a
sweater a little little rope slippers i've been
drinking like a gallon of water a day for like
three weeks how did you not feed and now i'm
just but i haven't drink any water damn oh
i think i'm starting to feel that effect yeah
dude you got to hydrate man very important so
i've had to pee love you dakota jones andy
andy b who i'm gonna tell john campbell
andy b who i'm going to pretend is andy bernard uh
do you see the possibility of seeing selena kyle
become the biggest villain to batman by the end of
the trilogy between bt dubs love the from belgium
belgium you gotta build the conflict that's
something they don't they have none of the live
actions have really done fully yet where it's like
[ __ ] they're the one thing that separates them
is catwoman's a [ __ ] thief you
know they just get on the same
goddamn page about stop stealing catwoman
you know yeah then we can just be together
because not even this movie does that
but they they tease some of like the
differences like i don't want to kill this
person but that's it doesn't really or like
she steals some money but then batman
finds out why and he's like oh i'm sorry
your dad was kind of a prick you deserve that
you should have that duffel bag of money you need
more i know a guy named bruce you can probably
get some some sort of donation the rich aren't
exactly spreading the wealth around this city you
see my dad tried and kind of [ __ ] us up maybe i
should care about the wealth because i could use
that i also love that they address the whole like
if batman's a billionaire why doesn't he just
put money into gotham which is a real thing
like in life in human in our life i think that's a
that's a quantifiable thing but i love the renewal
program being like that's why because like thomas
wayne tried to [ __ ] things up more yeah why
don't you become a billionaire and see if you're
going to give all your money i'd like to yeah
that's what everyone who not a billionaire says
but us billionaires on youtube jeff bezos is like
a billionaire jeff bezos's wife is single-handedly
helps slow the rainforest the deforestation of the
rainforest you'll never make it to a billion if
your goal is to give the billion away i'd like
that yeah i'd like that i would like i'd like that
i'd like that billionaires here on this channel
born in 1969 a bunch of muted out four tauruses
out there on the streets full of drug money harley
daniel coy i've been watching you since the early
mmn days what show i did matt key back in 2016.
[ __ ] mac he's [ __ ] matt key he looks like
pat reeves it's true it's true yeah well anyway
since the early mmn days what are
the chances of soups in this universe
in your opinion provided you haven't
heard what matt reeves says i would say
here's why you should be concerned
about the riddler's plan for golfing
cook this send it to me universe tick-tock and
matthew romney i think that uh superman should not
be in this universe because that negates a lot of
the ground reality of it i think that i think that
this being the anti-marvel movie in a lot of ways
is the best thing for comic book movies because
this isn't trying to build a shared universe
it's trying to build its own shared universe
we're getting tv shows we're getting movies
we're building out gotham but gotham should stay
isolated the batman comics occasionally dabble
but detective comics is largely the bat family
the batman comics are largely batman like if
you go too far shared then you lose this tone
and that specialness so i please to [ __ ] god
don't share this universe part of me is worried
that matt reeves is gonna spread himself
too thin with the two shows in the movies
two shows there's like like way
more apparently the arkham show
is the gotham show that's what i figured a
lot of people are forgetting about the k-pop
the cape crusader show the animated hbo max
one that him jj abrams oh yeah consulting
he can just say like good he's writing and
directing and hand animating every episode himself
he has talks with them about a catwoman james gunn
did it he didn't build the universe suicide squad
and peacemaker he's just begun the universe
and they were totally you know they worked
i think he can do it i think he can do it he made
cloverfield the biggest viral campaign of all time
like he's got that shared universe mentality yeah
i think he's got this give me seven shows and five
movies start the apes world a lot of people i
just love triumphant batman over here yes yes
a lot of people forget that he did not direct the
first apes movie who did let's see i don't even
know james franco director oh james franco
this is the guy's name you directed it you
literally just told me a lot you're like
people don't really think oh rupert grint
that's another guy rupert rupert the
chat right now chat guys in the chat
who who directed who directed dot poker you
directed rise of the planet of the apes or
yeah rise yeah john know you're planning to the
age of movies i mean obviously guys sorry anymore
yeah okay rupert wyatt rupert was eventually
right didn't he was the guy who got divorced
when he made uh uh snow white in the huntsman
yeah we don't talk about that sorry anyway moving
collision i want what did you find it i would
love peacemaking or sequel oh no i was waiting
for someone in the chat to point it out but i
don't think they're actually paying attention
no they're not they're still voting i
think we're just in the background it was
it was rupert wyatt this is probably the most
chaotic live we've had yet we're only an hour
and a half in never two hours in nerd collision i
want the guy with the puppet as the next villain
and hey that would uh build on the you know i
mean even though saw yes derived from seven it
would still build on the saw vibes for dopes like
me who were like there's a little jigsaw in there
i'm with it sal g what did y'all think about the
narrating parts of the story i loved it so much
and hope they keep doing it in future movies
this has been actually i'm fascinated to see
so many people debate this point in particular
on reviews i've debate uh people don't all love
shall i engage in this level of verbal jesting
today debates you say debate where on debate
point me to the podium show me the way where
are my note cards i will fight them yeah a
lot of people are torn and think the
narration frivolous and funny enough
and i am not the biggest comic book expert i
am i am the least of the comic book experts
in the square bubbles but to me that was
a thing where every batman comic i've ever
read practically i'm like that's the batman
narration that opens up so many comics is
i'm talking about what i'm doing well it's a city
it's square balls on voiceover circle bubbles
out loud it's a film noir and it's also in the
sense and the comic sense that but like people
check that and that's usually the excuse of
like but it's in that tradition so it's okay
but i'm like it's also in the direct tradition
of the comics it also has a movie that doesn't
have flashbacks so it lives in bruce wayne's
purview the whole time so why not have this
and the guy is [ __ ] sleep deprived is
jotting down his notes in a traditional
sense and then they write down the notes that he
said you literally see his voiceover in physical
yeah it's exactly this is his way of dealing
with his feelings because he can't talk to
anyone so he's just putting it down because
he's a [ __ ] madman that's up there with his
morning page that's he read the artist's
way it's called the gotham project yeah
it would be one thing if they did not explain
where the narration was coming from yeah that
then i would be like what why is he talking to the
audience you know but hello but did they explain
it and it's and it's not like in it throughout
it's only bookended by it yeah and uh it's like
who gives a [ __ ] guys we're here for three
hours you want to be three and a half now get
some narration yeah it works for me hashtag zero
so is this robert pattinson's best performance or
is the lighthouse still at the top i still think
it's a good time i still think it's the rover
is my favorite no but i think i think the
lighthouse i felt like was trying to be
an art house film and like it felt it's hard
to sit and get it wasn't enough bang bang
it wasn't enough bang bang wasn't it yeah guys
or bang bang mermaids why'd you spill your beans
well the lighthouse is very uh hp lovecraft new
england inspired like that is more hp lovecraft
than what a lot of people say is hp lovecraft
i want a lovecraft batman story yeah batman
versus the cthulhu yes the elder gods batman
dave lopez that would be a good man bat story
i want that oh man i want some marriages
i want man spider and man bat those are the
ones and the children and the batman who
laughs i want paul dano from riddler to go
up against willem dafoe from the lighthouse
ooh okay i want paul dano and daniel day-lewis
as harvey dent why just spill your bees
damn what's over we need dave lopez
dave favorite aspect of the movie mine
was gotham gotham's great in this movie
best co-star in the film and that's saying
something like the the second lead of this
film is gotham and it's incredible gotham
also great supporting character that
abandoned construction site that they meet at
all the time you can't say a movie tries to be
artsy like the lighthouse and then go
gotham second best character this succeeds
so yes i can say that i also said eternals
was an artist's film because the amount
of sunsets and holding hands i
stand by my standards i believe
uh yes i loved the gotham what time we
go live 11 11 30 should we cut off the
live chat thirty seven let's just turn
off the stream because what's up guys
i'm just monitoring the time you wanna do three
hours we started about 11 40. we started about
what you wanted to do because you said rewatch see
how we feel all right somebody in the chat says
he drinks your milkshake oh that's right he's
in there yeah yeah yeah that's my joke did you
think i was just naming actors yeah you brought it
full circle thank you bathroom boys for bringing
it full circle favorite aspect of the movie i just
love the the the rabbit hole of cinema traditions
it's borrowing from and so committed to and i
love that it really feels like a pulp noir novel
as much as a superhero movie just like
that poster i don't know i drive by the
billboard and you just see him with that side
eye just looking at you and i'm like that looks
like a detective movie just with batman yeah the
movie z larson 71. boom set your your slow pitch
you see that news uh newscaster made a whole
video about her obsession with the score and
it's her like harassing all of her co-anchors
running around things like doing like operatic
i'm a fan she's great let's do it i hope
the sequel takes place in the winter
a flooded gotham that is now frozen could be great
for penguin rising to power and perhaps mr freeze
that's fun i like that be fun yeah a lot of people
think penguin needs to be in like cold water a lot
of people think that he's gonna die if he doesn't
he's cold colin farrell needs to be in cold water
not the character and he needs to
lay and protect an egg at some point
at some point yeah yeah that's the easter egg that
is the easter egg it's full of marvel spoilers
does he like being called the penguin
i don't i thought he hates that
yeah i yeah but i would like i mean i think i
like the mr freeze idea with the cold though
i would love to see a batman movie in the snow
that would be cool yeah i think the visual
batman returns kind of has that yeah i think
every one of these should deal with weather
man there's guy pierce's little
kite man love in the uh comments
shaw agency we finally got to your super chat
thank you finally stop monologuing on every
question incredible incredibly generous
how do you squeeze out the time here
deke would love them to cover a hush or court of
al's storyline joker saved as the overall looming
big bad who's teased in each by the way keep
killing it guys love your content and always
stoke to see what you have in store i appreciate
that i appreciate that very generous ass super
chatbot thank you for a lot of money i think thank
you so much man kawaii it's all yours um i believe
that with the hush tease we got in the film which
was i it was so funny because i heard the name
and my brain immediately got so excited about hush
that i stopped thinking and then the third time i
watched it it literally says hush and i didn't
see it until the third time because every time
i was like oh and then i'm like they literally
[ __ ] spell out uh i do think there's a great
opportunity for falcone to have botched the
murder and maybe the guy got shot in the face
and now he's gotta you know do his hushiness uh
i think that could come and court of owls is is
i think an all but definite between reeves talking
about it patins and talking about it dano talking
about it like i think it talks about it like
it's it's just weird if it doesn't happen yeah
he's like have we not written that already like
it's like she knows that that was the plan he's
like tom holland right now he's just like have you
guys not read this happens ripped with cortisone
um so i think that is coming and i and i
personally think joker should wait a bit
i think the idea of joker and arkham is really
fun i like the sounds of the lamb's parallel
i also think barry cogan is very intense you
don't need him for a lot of time you just
have some like bursts of stuff but i also i don't
know i don't know if there's going to be an issue
with scheduling with barry cogan because he's
everywhere and if you want to do a full batman
thing like i don't know uh he'll make time i
mean it's batman yes and it's the character
i think there's so much pressure to be the
joker that's that's because you know like
when you're the joker man like even for me i
go didn't really much an impression on me like
i'm judging this whole subconsciously i find
myself judging this whole guy's performance
off of like joker 15 seconds right you don't
even get him like wait but i don't even have
an actual i think like remind myself of
like i don't have an actual scene with him
he's obscured you know so and that's kind
of the pressure and i'm noticing like no
one really usually you're stinging that's what
everyone talks about like if it's a marvel movie
yeah you know but what's great is the movie was so
good we're talking about the score we're talking
about the batman we're talking about the movie
yeah i do think you know obscured through glass
not able to really see anything it's hard to
judge i agree with you you're judging the voice
yeah laughter you're you're trying to but
i've never been unimpressed by barry coke
and performance so i feel like he would crush it
if we got a scene like if we actually had some
stuff with him like hopefully the deleted scene
i know just because he's irish and the penguins
also actually it's not like the old country's
taking over the batman and he worked with colin
farrell and killing of a sacred gear true second
collapse between the irishman one thing i did
like about the joker is his hair i was
like oh cool the frizzy kind of upward
i'm about it they should do a joker
verse movie just all the jokers
that is gonna turn into a cgi deep fake
nightmare because you know they would i
know they would come together and then
they would just start killing each other
five minutes yeah yeah would they kill each
other or would they kill everybody else
they would be like let's team up we could have
this city but then they'd slowly be trying to like
kill off each other yeah yeah they wouldn't hand
place five jokes it would be like hate working it
would be like war of the roses but with the jokers
i think it would be actually great or the joke is
yeah that'd be great and artist
reflect somehow winds up on top
i could say that for for what they
would do with that silliness yeah
um but the camera monohand he was perfect five
camera monohands because he had so many jokers
he played two yeah yeah he's multiple jokers
i'm into that he was great zach galifianakis
sarah campbell just popping in to say hey and
leave a smiley face hooray for sarah campbell
all the love thank you for showing joining
and hey hey congrats on your move by the way
i hope it's uh you're settling in well michael
mack uh loved the flim how about victor zazz
as a villain if done right he can be super
creepy was well done in the arkham knight
game and hey shouts out to i'm forgetting
the actor's name but are you yawning
no i haven't slept and watched the batman too
much i think maybe i'm not gonna make a joke
who played him in birds of prey was it christmas
like he was so so good and i feel i i i don't
expect or or actually probably want this to happen
but i can see that character working in this world
all right guys listen of his portrayal but yeah
i agree that tone does work but victor zazz is
the best he's going to be with christmas you know
no disrespect whoever plays him next but that was
incredible jesus christ guys the gotham show
i'm gonna keep bringing this [ __ ] show love
the gospel the god who have you guys seen the show
barry yeah i've seen some episodes who's the who's
the guy who who hides anthony is it oh anthony yes
bald guy carrick bros carrick the guy who hasn't
seen much of barry knows anthony i know anthony
kerrigan is impressive he's dennis caleb mccoy
yeah yeah that's right yeah um that's why
he was showdown champ right here this guy
internationally here guys aren't you lucky to
have me coy all the good i've done for your
factions doing great work this season listen
guys anthony kerrigan in in gotham was awesome
as victor's ass and he was great you guys should
watch gotham this is just a three-hour gotham ad
well i'm not gonna lie man i think the best alfred
was in gotham better than michael kane i'd say so
wow hot take it's not if you've seen it that's
true it's not even a take for me because i haven't
seen it better than lego alfred that's that's
the question better than michael go buckle goes
actually pretty great i just love how every
movie i've been recording your identity batman
upload that to instagram and that's the teaser
to get people into the live stream weirdly talk
about gotham this will be great greg will die
on the hill of trying to get you to watch gotham
i will die on the hill of being like hey asians
if shield's actually pretty good you guys have
yeah you guys have the side
missions in this year versus
joking birds of prey and gotham he's
funny but he's also a badass like an
actual yeah relationship between the
two of them i only saw it one time
i've seen it ten times i don't remember not more
than the batman um anyway let's move on guys
hey nathan winning winning did you guys see the
theory that the green liquid shot batman takes
is actually venom and uh he's got that adrenaline
momentum i would love to see bane in this universe
i think bane later for me like i said earlier
um but i i personally don't think that was venom
um but it could have been i don't know what color
adrenaline is from the hospital but you can't deny
that he had the adrenaline momentum oh yeah and
they didn't know what hit him when they got hit
with that venom uh that i believe i believe crazy
[ __ ] in the end somehow he like planted all
those explosions at the top that was a distinction
that wouldn't fall on the crowd of people
was did batman blow up the roof that's dangerous
as hell i definitely didn't yeah it was like we
did he planned that yeah yeah i was like
i don't know the first time i saw it was
like oh i thought that was riddler business and
then each subsequent time i'm like no i think
that's batman but also hundreds of people
blow the whole roof up couldn't just blow
why not rain glass too they're not enough
danger drowning and electrocuting you gotta
throw some glasses i believe actual i
believe actual testosterone is clear
if you look at the batman comics like batman
it's kind of huge just to land in that one spot
it's a dome it's gigantic i need to save
these people let me flow from the wounds
that i've given them with all this glasses at
least a third of the space of the floor there
like you guys movie glass is not real
no i'm not talking about like film
making glass i'm saying like the
way glass is played in movies if
you jump through a glass window
you're all right [ __ ] up movies you're always up
dust this off i'm like that's not a glass in real
life shouts out to the nice guys when he tries to
break that window and ends up bleeding everywhere
he goes to the hospital he's like oh oh no great
great uh if you haven't seen it go watch that
noir next eric mcintyre what a double feature that
would be a great and hey you'd get your laughs in
uh giancarlo esposito should definitely be mr
freeze holy [ __ ] is that a fan casting then that
that's been going around i love that i can
already see it i can see the eyes i can't play
every villain though i like ron sephis jones as mr
freeze for me i like nick offerman as the servers
the mustache under the dome time
to kick some ice that's real good
that was so good what killed the dinosaurs
holy [ __ ] have you done a [ __ ] before
wonderful i just hear his voice echo through my
head it is a great kick offer oh yeah he would he
would like to see that yeah yeah yeah
incredible yeah and he's got such a loving eye
but also intensity so he'd like love on nora
then like murk the batman love this guy i want
to see benjamin as mr freeze gotham did not have a
good mr freeze yes finally some gotham disdain oh
they had it sorry they had a good introduction
but when he became freeze it wasn't good all right
that's fair that's honestly just like just having
to walk around and freeze people once in a while
what about what about a giancarlo harvey dead i'm
into that good if we can finally see a guy a good
guy at least a little bit of a good half a good
guy and then a conflicted bad guy sort of maybe
yeah well two faces like becomes a crime lord we
he has to we have to get him there yeah that's
why i like that they didn't kill off riddler right
i'm like oh my god finally villains have villains
to carry on like and also welcome can become this
great like source of like villainy i think i think
he's building like okay i'm going to tell
you guys what my dark detective series is
going to be and i feel like matt reeves is
doing the same thing you [ __ ] thief you
basically he's building up the bat burst he's
building i think he's building up the bat family
and building up this rogues gallery and then i
think it'll culminate into an arkham asylum movie
i'm dying for that i'd love that right i
want because that flag was going to skip
right there to that i think it'd be way more
deserved if we've met all these villains yeah
let's just get right to it we should
make a justice league the second movie
movie that's what they told jesus to do
batman v superman just go right to it
i don't want to call them they're like
baba dukes snyder fans they'll appear
i don't hey man snyder fans are
great i like no i'm a snyder
oh i we are not mocking zack snyder
for those who get hypersensitive uh
just loving paul dana that's all we're doing
the [ __ ] i you guys know how big of a fan i
have in those movies i still think they can
[ __ ] do it guys i think justin's number
we have a batman we got a joker everything but dc
has established a multiverse thoroughly and their
nest point is going to serve discovery wants to
do it [ __ ] okay well and i'm sure that somebody
with money other than wb would join up and be like
yeah we'll finance some of this you guys don't
have to take the risk all of my billions i'm gonna
get a house and put up my mortgage to finance
sliders just like this is how it's done robo eye
and zearing do you think a r rating would benefit
this movie i thought when batman unmasked
the riddler uh thug after going off on him
he wasn't bloody enough i was actually surprised
by how violent it was to when it happened well
and the [ __ ] the the f word at the beginning
of the movie flew right past me partly because
i assumed there were way more of them because i
forgot about the rating completely so the pg-13
works for me because i'd rather have five of these
movies than two and i think the budget allows for
them like you can make a lot more of their pg-13
like it's just it's a more profitable uh and if
it doesn't feel like it hinders the film i didn't
mind it there were a couple times that i was aware
of it being like oh that blood is the exact amount
they can do but it didn't bother me well i think
uh the way it riffs because david it riffs so
much on fincher films which are bloody adventure
films are [ __ ] violent yeah like it really when
i espec weirdly the scene it stood out to me as is
whenever you're at the dead bodies like the thumb
removed you don't really get a good shot of it
yeah or the pull of blood they pull the blood they
say there's so much blood the when they're down
in the i think it's the morgue when uh the rat
maze the first time he finds the rat maze and
they're they're literally looking at a dead
body of the commissioner yeah looking at the
dead body of the commissioner and you never
see it yeah and because it's supposed to be
all mutilated from what fincher would have done
and i think adventure movies i mean obviously
they're a different genre um but i think if they
didn't if you hadn't seen them you wouldn't notice
like if you hadn't seen finger movies i don't
think you'd notice in this movie that's less
bloody perhaps your heads i still think it
like tone and mood wise this feels r-rated
like there's a version of this where i'm surprised
matt reeves is saying like there's never an r-rate
he said there's never been an r-rated cut of this
and it's kind of surprises me because like really
i think he was smart to walk the line that he did
and it feels enough well and for a year for for
the past like a three-hour r-rated movie like this
yeah it's like it's fast that's three it's one ask
two minutes yeah exactly like it's already only
playing three times per house in a cinema you
can't also make it rated and expect to make money
like this like logan has a faster pace and is like
hyper violent right up front to hook your audience
you know yeah so that's why i think logan has a
little bit of ener extra entertainment quality
because like the violence in there is so like
visceral and gory and i think that like keeps
you engaged more yeah when i feel like filmmakers
in the past decade or so have gotten really
conscientious and i guess good at making pg-13
movies feel like they're rated or like portraying
intensity and certain states of either terrorism
well yeah not showing you too much but really
solidifying it in like the grit of how they
capture it and all that like i for whatever reason
the robocop remake really struck me that way is
like if you look at those scenes like when they're
showing like terrorism overseas i'm like this is
kind of disturbing footage if you took it out of
context i also there's this weird thing where like
mega bros mega rated bros are like it actually
wasn't that scary or intense i'm like this
movie's [ __ ] intense like i hate when people
are like it's pg-13 therefore it's not intense
because this movie is intense and scary i mean
other people who are like i saw this happening
to comment on a recent video of them saying the
marvel netflix shows weren't that r-rated really
and i was like they decapitate a guy with a car
door like yeah watch any of daredevil the punisher
jessica jones everything jessica jones talks
about they're like you can't even get away
even the sex scenes and jessica jones don't have
nudity like but they that still wouldn't fly in
a pg-13 movie to that level no no yeah people
are and the people are like they're gonna have
to cut them down like till what and daredevil
when that guy like literally doesn't want to
like no you can't send me a fisk he like shoves
his head into a spike yeah i'm like that would
have been a pg-13 movie that is so violent that's
why there's a parental code coming to disney plus
not yeah it's so silly it's uh so yeah there
are those there are those like already i've
never heard that did you make that up r-rated
bro heads i've yeah i just made that up in this
moment that's good just just now copyrighted
trade market because that is a good way to price
r is the only acceptable rate yeah like if there's
a poster on my wall this is pg-13 it sucks like
even if it's just for a scene of strong language
i'll take the i want a second [ __ ] or just some
smoking or something please yeah the cigar with
penguin like then it'd be good yeah it sucks back
then there were movies that are like rated r for a
brief strong language yeah yeah these poor sons of
i remember there were a couple movies
i did see growing up where i was like
i thought because this was rated r i was
gonna see something like kind of edgy
but this is just like a drama where they say
the f word a couple times just like a real life
thank you for the moment of silence you are
lovely and we love you uh manuel rodriguez uh
how much do you feel r-rated would a matter
not i appreciate this man well um i would say
if you can rewind the video back ten minutes
you go on a tear a really qualitative answer
nc17 is the best appreciate the support um dougie
okay hear me out a proper bane the adrenaline
awful lot like venom guys you feel mr freeze mad
hatter poison ivy or even calendar man or saws
i think that one stuck in if you can fall off
a mad hatter that's what i've been taking man
that would be mad um instead of scarecrow i think
we don't we do there's poison ivy just seems so
supernatural but i would love to see if there is a
way to pull off a poison ivy i want poison i mean
in a catwoman movie i don't want it it would be
hot you know what i mean like well because also
it gets it gives zoey kravitz the ability to like
actually show that she can connect with someone
like zoe kravitz isn't like did she bisexual or
character yeah and like we got living with monica
dating right so but i'd love to actually see her
love someone i'd love to see like and that would
allow for the cat in the bat when she comes back
to have impact and that would also allow for us
to feel for poison ivy so i'd introduce poison ivy
and catwoman and then i i want mad hatter because
i also think it'd be really fun to play with alice
in wonderland imagery in this world i'd love the
idea of like instead of riddles you've got some
strange tangible elements instead of supernatural
like alice in wonderland exists it'd be fun to
play with that stiffs all right guys look here's
my pitch for poison ivy okay batman is uh out with
the boys at the wayne accounting firm partying it
up snorting coke you know at the strip club and
then him and the boys uh they're so [ __ ] wasted
that they start pissing in the trees and the
park and they're ruining like just pretty much
all the grass and they they set some bushes
on fire poison ivy's there and that's when
she's like i gotta go after this bruce wayne
billionaire punk yep and it's all because
this is about the consequences of bruce wayne
and now he is suffering the repercussions and
only batman could save them okay i gotta follow a
pitch we got a movie uh it stars i don't know mark
wahlberg um maybe a uh zoe saldana uh no no let's
go let's go zoe ditching out and then we've got uh
directed by you know like a thrill drink like m9
shyamalan and basically it's uh it's nature uh i.e
the wind oh it's come on like batman the happening
or something that happened like it's about john
leguizamo i think john was almost there and mark
robert plays a teacher that's what you do yeah
get the lady in the water in the next batman
man i think we're just having
a conversation and forgetting
riddle me this the puppet answered his quest
don't think i forgot the question it was
i don't remember two hours ago i asked where the
tutor was behind on the street what theater was
that in this is what i was telling you at the
very top every time like we cannot spin forever
guys answer me this question don't worry catwoman
did selena just abandon her cats no she brought
don't put it in the little oh okay but just one
so the rest were full of cats okay i guarantee
that was a motorcycle full of cats they were
attached with a rope just run behind the bike you
have so many little pockets i imagine they're all
see when batman made a right and she made a left
there were all those cats she's following her man
that's right there's they mixed the meows very
low footsteps and meows from the question the
puppet raul ranjan pattinson seriously needed
to work on his bruce wayne he felt so much like
batman bw is a mask and it shouldn't be same as
batman solid detective movie he never had to wear
the mask because he was never around people you
know look we have to factor this in we are like
an hour and a half behind on there okay they've
probably heard extensive multiple reasonings
so uh you know i mean i'm just saying like keep
raul if you're sticking around we acknowledge
your thoughts and emotions we probably can't
change it because whatever you've said you've
probably heard someone already you know counter
that with something similar to what we said
so uh yeah you know just feel
the way you're gonna feel
what's the dollar symbol in front of that i in all
that is uh uh indian rupees oh rupees that's cool
i've never seen this i know you and your white
privilege i just don't i don't deal in rupees
often i do that makes sense yeah we have to
calculate the exchange rate what do you think
i buy the equipment from with rupees that's what's
in the back of that everything comes in and then
we translate for it to rupees and that's how we
do our business that explains taxes estapon man at
the beginning and the fear of criminals both the
shadows in that signal i was in from the moment on
to me that is batman yes what's wrong john i'm
agreeing i said boogie which is an affirmation
in my world possessive affirmation boogie boogie
yeah and i completely agree with that that's my
that's my favorite opening man that's terrific
it's a plus i'm so tired i sounded drunk you just
had a little slur action yeah batman and i'll go
on record and say i i find a distinction between
his bruce and his bathroom i see one as well
there is one's a [ __ ] boy yeah he likes your
swings a boy feel like a boy when he's bruised
he's like not he you see a boy like that's how
he interacts with people he's there's a bit of
like an angsty childish [ __ ] to him you know
he lighted me up i don't want to go to
bruce who don't want to be accountable
or care about the accountants even though that's
probably how i get all my gadgets you think you're
a wayne alfred and then he's like walking through
the funeral like oh but then when he's batman he's
like well [ __ ] i'm batman like it's such a yeah
it's just not bruce wayne playboy it's it's bruce
wayne recluse and batman well when he's batman
you feel the boy doing his best to embody more
of a man that's true too you know jamie hutchinson
i think i think there's a major distinction and
everyone needs to chill out everyone just goes
they're both brooding and that's what they boil it
down to well of course he's going to bring some
of that in well he's got to have a motivation
also bruce and bat both broke but that's part of
the point of it is that when he puts on the mask
he is complete at that moment yeah that's the
point so of course he's going to be partially
there when he's got the yeah it's like this is
who he really feels he is like riddler and riddler
having said that that's why he's saying like that
is the real exactly god damn it's in the movies
it's been driving me crazy i've been on the
internet too much jamie hutchinson hi all
loved the batman i would like to see the court
of owls in the sequel what do you think love
these live discussions yes yes a thousand times
yet all the elves yeah we should end the super
chat okay because he's drunk we're pausing
i'm not it's drunk yeah i could probably do
that from a separate window let's see we got so
if you want to read the next one i'll just uh
all right coy my dude what up next graphic
novel purchase dark victory or [ __ ] hush i
love long halloweening you're one i always love
watching your live streams guys oh thank you
i just wrote down uh money slash orphan for my
next tick talk to remind me what to film next
you just wrote a rap i saw you i'm just doing i
got i just thought of a rhyme with edward nigma
ooh what are you rhyming there i was
gonna say shmegma but it has actually
uh i would say hush big pharma it doesn't actually
um dark knight returns yes dark victory so
you would have to read dark knight returns
which i assume they hurt but also hush is a great
jumping on point for any batman book like hush is
kind of one of those greatest hits where you
get a lot of villains you get detective work
you get gorgeous gymly art you get uh a batman
at the height of his powers like i think batman
hush is one of the greatest approachable bat
stories so i always say people should read
hush if you haven't dude just watch the hush
animated movie read comics don't watch movies
except when we're talking about the movie
adaptation people read more comics movies are
doing just fine read comics that's fair actually
the saddest thing about going to comic-con to me
it was the the first year i worked at comic-con i
was walking around i had to do social media posts
and nothing would post and i was walking around
the floor and then all of a sudden like 12 of
them went through immediately and i looked up and
i was like oh i'm in the part of the hall where
the comic books are you're in the artist alley
so no one's yeah that's no not even artist alley
it was where the comic books were being sold
yes it's my area but yeah so read comics hush
let's go real rejects just the nobody's podcast
says we love your reaction villain villain videos
what batman video oh shoot you got a
thousand over a thousand people watching yeah
there was a time when it was like we were only
two hours ago 100 viewers was very worried and
i was like what the likes are but we're so in zoom
100 that is impressive what batman villain do you
hope to see next in live action well we said this
earlier but you probably came in late or we just
got around to your question late i was saying i
would love to see kite man be the main villain
or perhaps i would like to see like one of
the henchmen who happened to survive one of
the fights in the batman as the leader as the
main villain who just hasn't has a bone in pick
you beat me and my friends up and embarrass me on
appreciation night we totally don't get as many
members oh the henchman that could be the name of
the villain yeah yeah the batman the henchman sort
of the long halloween the hand the entrance just
the henchmen just the hints i uh i think that the
only way to get sean connery out of retirement is
to have him play kite man so i heard to resurrect
sir billy i thought a league league of
extraordinary journal was his last movie
i thought he retired no he did sir billy
he does the scottish animated masterpiece
i think i'm learning sean connery died
dude this was a couple of years ago no
embarrassing probably more than that
now i want to say i don't know anyhow
uh hey eric nieble was the best introduction
scene to batman ever 20 20 we were all a little
busy yeah that's fair i missed it that's fair
i was watching spider-man [ __ ] i did not have
time to learn i was trapped inside my house with
nothing much to do i did not know i couldn't find
it out completely i was missing i was watching
i blocked all deaths from my sms section anyway
william all right william faison i'd love
to see batman vs deathstroke live action
fight it would be so gritty brutal well shot
and matt reeves proved he'd be up to it to
[ __ ] just get ben affleck to play deathstroke
how cool would that get ben affleck to play all
the supporting characters every rogue ben affleck
i think no one should ever respect ben affleck
wanting to have his own [ __ ] life take away from
this man i feel so bad for that guy like let him
be the unbearable weight of massive no matter no
matter how we saw how this maid he was when he
was making these he's gonna be in the director's
chair with just the slow zoom in hello darkness my
friend the entire time poor guy ah a leaf
you're back a leaf bear all depends on the right
support system so maybe with the right support
system you know yeah mm-hmm a good broadcast
one of her oscar dresses was it was like a poison
ivy yeah it was like plant life yeah dude okay ben
affleck that's how we get back that's how we get
him to not do a thing he wants to do how did she
stay so attractive oh you do notice the illuminati
exercise i think it's just just genetics
i think she's got a lot going for a personal
trainer she's a good energy she's in positive
affirmations journaling hydrating watching
increased dragged across concrete all right uh
eleph buyer lashi have you seen ben shapiro's
review no but i'll probably watch it i'm so
excited coming up he hates the film and say he
thinks more about the more it makes him angry
the complete opposite for me the more i think
about it the more i love it look i'm not going
to lie to you guys i'm a hard alt-right i love
mentioning all about bastion daily wire should
have made the batman all right uh no i i uh i i
don't off 99 of the time agree with ben shapiro
however he is that rare personality that i
could watch something from him once in a while
and genuinely find it entertaining like in a way
where i'm not like offended in the slightest like
they're like the whop the watt music video the rap
the white ass [ __ ] music did you see that his
commentary his reaction yes oh my god his reaction
is so hilarious he just like doesn't understand
what is going on with these women he's like what
is it wrong yeah it is so funny it is one of the
fun it's not as a joke it does like it doesn't
play like that like a joke because he's almost
colbert-esque and that he should be a joke like
he's almost like a parody of what he's just such
a specific personality he's also the definition of
a dry [ __ ] yeah and that's why and i saw i can
sometimes find him like really when he's talking
i'm talking about when he's talking about like
movies or something stuff that doesn't actually
have an impact on people but he's talking about
like political [ __ ] that i'm like i'm not
really gonna tune into this but when he's like
reviewing a films i could just find it hilarious
how he like uh sometimes takes something yeah i
don't delight very much in people getting
pwned via video essay but i do enjoy it
ben shapiro's hot take sucks videos so one of him
like when he's like when when people just move
out of your houses and sell them to who aquaman is
very timely for this conversation like here it is
yeah ben shapiro big dc fan out there hey go
on to joe rogan o'reilly get that spotify money
now now they let me have an open house a little
more vacant a lot more people are not going to
go on now oh hey alif wants to know who would you
cast as harvey d in this universe michael b jordan
idris elba uh tom hardy he's my superman to be
honest but i'd say sterling k brown would crush
sterling k brown is sorry that would be rad
because he i could see him as a d.a i could
also see him really angry i could see him
playing someone that has like a strong moral
compass that's decided like that like i think
honestly sterling cape brown would be great
and we'd finally get that [ __ ] billy williams
nod that we should have had as harvey done
why would we get the billy d williams because he
was supposed to be harvey knight he was supposed
to be two-faced in the third movie that timber
never got why would sterling k brown be the he's
an african-american man we've never had a so that
would be a two-face that would be a nod because
he's black yeah so does zerodec harden nod to
tommy lee jones yeah because he's white no we've
never had a black toothpaste and in the comics
we have and in the movies we were supposed to so
i think it'd be nice too all right henry what is [
__ ] up about the timber about what happened there
that is [ __ ] up they literally whitewashed
that's like that was the literal definition
of white watching however harvey ten who was
black and then what ring and tom allegiance
so that's why i know you're giving me [
__ ] but that's why i want like a black
two face because like we were supposed to
good call and people are always going a lot
of people so complain about the other way
around people are like oh they cast this
person it's like well there are people who
think who is the guy in uh in don't look up
steven lang
the guy in don't look up who's like the actual
government representative that they start to
work with i think he could be a good harvey
dent the government government don't look up
mark ryan like the main black actor in the
cast i don't remember that movie very well
it was so [ __ ] like this is a metaphor like
it was so heavy-handed i love that movie it
doesn't quite do satire so much we got him two
hours of intelligence alex b is back reeves is
hinted thank you that uh batman has previously
apprehended this not yet joker gcpd series
see like i'm having such a hard time
imagining batman not being in this show
especially with the year one
like what's like what's the year
he just like runs like in signs like
he's always like the alien and signs like
like we just see a cake that's like oh that's
batman but if there's one you could see it
happen because of the fact that robert
pattinson does not need to show his face
also he could live in the shadows striking fear
in the criminal like we could build that up where
like he's always the element in the shadows like
jaws like he pops up in two episodes never have
a scene with gordon and him talking well they
don't meet in the movie see i've always met by
the time we get to batman year two that's what i
mean it's like you could bring him in later i've
what i've wanted for the longest time for a
batman year one adaptation is to live in the dark
what i've wanted for the longest time for a batman
year one adaptation i've said this like multiple
times is that you do batman year one but you
never like just show the audi you just keep it
in gordon's perspective like you never show the
audience that like we know because we [ __ ] know
but you don't show that bruce wayne and batman
are one and the same yeah you don't have to do
a scene that shows any of that you just keep it in
gordon's perspective sometimes you interact with
batman you have to go to something where bruce
wayne is there but the movie never goes they're
the same i love that idea especially with this
batman we've built because he's so rarely bruce
yeah yeah so i'd be right it would work for this
universe that's what i mean so you can bring that
in and like like like in batman year one there's
a shootout scene where we're batman where batman's
like about to [ __ ] up some cops and gordon's
outside and like and so much of what gordon deals
with is like is this batman and what the the [
__ ] he's doing is this the right path to go down
you know he's finding himself tempted to be a
little bit more outside of the law by doing some
vigilante [ __ ] kind of going against the books
so you can have those same scenes from batman
you're one ripped out you just don't ever have
to cut to batman monologue or something like that
you know yeah i'd love to see a show where you
actually are like i know something in the audience
like in cass doesn't know more like year fun
walter lopez in the chat says batman will never
stop beating the crap out of people but this time
he'll have empathy i appreciated that our dosh
raju jeffrey wright as gordon your thoughts love
love loved jeffrey wright and i know uh greg and
i uh you remarked this to me and i absolutely
adore the way he always refers to him as man
the casualness i'm like come on man we gotta
go yeah man i think yeah i don't even know
what's your thing the the flippant nature of
like i got my boys dressed like a bat like uh
i personally think and i and i said this after
our third viewing that he might have taken over
my favorite gordon from gary old and which is [
__ ] insane like ariel and such a good gordon and
gary oldman reminds me of the comic book um year
one uh barbara is about to have a kid like that
whole element gordon but this the relationship
between the two of them was so strong and it's so
batman that it might have taken over that i prefer
the dynamic between gordon and batman in this one
i but i i still prefer gary oldman but that but i
think of gary oldman i think a lot of like scenes
in the dark knight yeah i have to save dent yeah
but also at the end he's like i'm sorry forever
yeah like that moment i i think gary oldman
doesn't get enough credit for his the work he
puts in yeah for the dark knight in all
three movies he's so consistent and his
arc is really subtle as it grows and changes
yeah yeah i agree he's incredible bruce wayne
also just that
i only put a coat on one boy my whole life
and i never got that coat back you must be
[ __ ] bruce wayne i've sent so many letters
to your house i have dispatched countless
officers to wayne manor to get my goddamn
coat back i have been cold for 30 years
i never thought the one coat
all right boy just the one i
gary oldman has that quality of the authority
figure who i who i like i can imagine people in
my life who have looked at up at as authority
figures and he embodies that whereas jeffrey
wright i love that he is like on the street
level with you he feels more like he's he's
served like time on the streets of gotham
getting beaten down yeah like i feel like
he's deserved time so true but i have a crazy idea
what let's see we're we're here now keep running
we gotta i then i gotta dispute a copyright
claim on that computer that we just got
on this uh no on a different oh i've been on this
this is an e-cigarette it's only zero milligrams
in here oh that really sucks when it's zero
i missed the the mystery becky all right
it's okay if you position it right away no no we
got it here we'll read the next super chat while
you figure out how to make that one i'm going to
dispute this copyright claim is it a copyright
in this video we're currently doing no no no
a different one oh okay but it's getting views
this one so i gotta dispute it in real time it's
happening this is what it's like to make youtube
do you want the laptop would that be easier uh
i think so let's just have my ass peeking back
yeah all right or at least in the gmail uh hey
jay's content is being flipped something already
yeah with the clip should we watch it while
we're watching it yeah let's watch it's our worst
moment just combined and because it takes his
time you can really feel all the influence i'm
going to make a big statement that i think people
are going to see is hyperbole i think this is the
movie as much as logan was that's going to save
the medium i don't consider it a genre anymore
that section oh good hey thanks pdx uh pdx nerd
thank you very much for clipping us out i'm gonna
share this heck yes uh so jay's content says
bane step bro in sequel to continuing history
so uh what do you think bane as batman's step
brother john you're gonna have to hold down the
john c reilly is gonna play bane and uh robert
pattinson is gonna rub his nuts on the drum kit
of love that bring that to netflix talking
about velociraptors and [ __ ] like running
around and then you could get richard jenkins boom
commissioner gordon right in the comments writes
itself get mary steenburger the catwoman the
batman or no get uh who's agatha get get katherine
han to be catwoman gordon but just because of the
adam mckay universe adam scott can be the riddler
get rob wriggled to be the penguin
it's the entire cast of stepbrother
if someone doesn't make this
fan art i have failed the city
because step bros batman is amazing what is their
thing called what worldwide anyway uh patrick ak
oh enterprise elite worldwide i forget uh this was
the best live-action graphic novel i've ever seen
i was blown away that there were three movies
in one pretty much yeah yep that's a great way
to put it absolutely but not feeling like it's
oscillating between the like it feels like it
blends them and and jumps between them quite well
or they're all you know ass aspects of the city
uh extra for seven or christopher 7 if
you're being clever oh that is clever
that's clever nice nice hey guys that's not your
currency but i'm just going australian anyway uh
i'd like to know your reactions to all the comic
book inspired moments i went nuts when the moments
from long halloween year zero year one etc uh
so many amazing comic moments what is clp um
that's a great question it's a large amount
while you answer to your expertise i'll find it
all right clp uh i really really want this i'll
throw one answer there i completely forgot that
the comic reveals that catwoman is the daughter
of falcone or at least like heavily implies right
the the kid of falcone is the is the calendar man
in in long halloween but i thought there was one
that that's that pretty much implies that catwoman
is the daughter of yeah it's not enlisted in those
but i think there was it's just not as me i i
i think i know what you're referencing but i
don't know what ark it's from but i i did feel i
remember watching that scene in the movie going
oh [ __ ] like i did say that like oh damn yeah
i gotta tell you that was coming i was like whoa
that was that's a crazy reveal right there i
think that was the biggest surprise the first
time around and it works watching it again going
like oh like all that connective tissue really
uh for me seeing the zero gear stuff between the
motorcycle when i was like oh they're gonna use
the tech from zero year then they actually [ __ ]
did the flooding to that level uh i was impressed
um i really liked some of the visuals from
tim sale who who illustrated long halloween
so this felt like a tim sale drawing come
to life uh as far as like energetically
the voice over which we've talked about quite a
bit is very much year one like i could almost see
the handwriting that he has being the handwriting
from year one as well as like that riddler scene
whereas in the diner from year one that was really
cool um the batmobile feels almost like the darren
aronofsky uh take on your one like where it's
a guy that works at a mechanic's place that's
like really really street level um so that kind of
reminded me of like a combination of an adaptation
we never got and the comic book itself yeah um you
know i mean it kind of felt like hey we were going
to do this thing let's put all that together um
a lot of really beautiful stuff from the comics
uh and yeah what's clp it's chilean pesos oh
that's cool hey shout out to chile and uh and alex
villalobos says steve harvey is mr freeze
bring that mustache into the dc eu you
should just get jay pharaoh to play that'd be
awesome he could do anybody uh red eight that
batmobile introduction guys oh wow i love how
that is the first time you see it yeah yeah
and then the next time you see it he just pulls
up different like i actually find that shotgun
commissioner we've talked about that's
my spot no i don't got a little batman
sign on it like the studios he's got his
little batman parking space signal yeah
uh dude how did you feel about very quickly the
transition to the chase because i've heard i've
had debates about it and i've heard you know
people question you know like did it need to
become a chase because it seems very deliberate
that batman makes it a chase i think he was
instilling fear in the penguin okay i think like
the whole thing is like he's a piece of vengeance
and he hasn't had a chase yet like he hasn't had
to show i mean obviously he didn't want to get
his collateral damage but like i do think there
was an element of hunt that he wanted to instill
fear in the penguin because penguin doesn't fear
him john had a good uh rationale that he was
trying to lure them away from the like there was
gordon exposed there was a catwoman he wanted to
lure them like get him in a chase that way they
learn because everyone's got like a machine guns
yeah well yeah he's got a new z and i feel like
i cut that i cut that out of our new rocks when
we covered the easter egg i cut it out just to
save some time on the video oh sure and so yeah
well yeah because like the other instances
of machine gun use in the movie are all close
quarters and penguin has an uzi which is like
way more portable than a rifle and like if he
gets near batman's face at all batman's done
for us so i feel like that it hit me in the
shot where he's looking through the window as
penguin is blasting the window with the gun
of like oh okay you probably needed a tank deal
with this yeah yeah yeah that's a really cool
ins i didn't thought of that like he needed
the tool that is his car to take out penguin
yeah so i think it's it's also what you said
because that charge is is a literal challenge
and then at the end penguin's face of like i fear
this man now yeah like when she hadn't yet yeah
so yeah and i that chase like one of the best all
righty the raider nation 33. reeves didn't make
a comic book movie he made a graphic novel
it won't be he said this before all of you
we're going back to the age group novels i'm going
after the audience now yeah yeah weird move greg
segregated these guys just make it awkward and
attack your audience shahzad in the chat says
ben shapiro's oracle not batwoman but oracle
uh the raider nation 33 reeves didn't make
a comic book movie made a graphic novel it
won't be as commercial as nolan's but this
is the batman i wanted it was perfect i
literally made a tick tock today about
the box office and i was like for a low budget
film it's incredible that it's already made 128
which is the second film of the pandemic era to
clear 100 million is opening weekend but i said
low budget and people are like it cost 200
million yeah it cost 100 extra millions they
were inventing covet protocols this was originally
100 million budget so even 200 million dollars is
less than the average superhero film which is 250
275 thereabouts 100 million budget this movie's
insane i think it's really smart for matt reeves
to keep making things in this one to 150 range
so that way it can stay as authentic and
doesn't need to be as broad strokes to the
audience as nolan um but that's just me i'd
love to have more indies like logan and this
i concur with these statements heavily i forgot
what i'm dispute i forgot what i did to dispute
that claim um there was a point here to be
made that i can't remember at all right now
he made a graphic novel it won't
be as commercial as nolan's because
this is the batman bro oh i took my friends um
tony courtney and i thought they were going to be
bored out of their minds i really thought they
would be very bored uh just i don't really know
their taste in movies but they don't really watch
like they're they're you know i mean tony does but
for some reason somebody just told me they're
just like regular folks you know they're not
like reading comics or anything like that you
know they're not like this is what batman has
to they're not they're not like those people
and then uh they watched it and they were
like that was fantastic that was like a great
detective movie it kind of reminded me of sevens
they're saying these things and i was like okay so
yeah you don't have to they're not like film but
like they really have like a dog walking business
that's like their life you know so that's great
there's just people right not one dog in the movie
they're they're except the swimming regular folks
we shouldn't do that what's
happening here oh i thought
i thought we were being we were i thought
i was like oh no we got to be considerate
uh we thought we weren't no we just love your
insights i shot we shot that dc leagues the
super pets trailer reaction and i gotta still edit
that well the live stream is done now that's what
i thought we were going to oh man julian marian
says robert pattinson is batman life of nate
says pattinson's batman voice was the best damn
those two stacked together come on you got some
good looking audience members man boogie that's
true that's true you guys should get together this
little tiny image of you guys from like six feet
away like you guys are attractive human beings
i don't actually know what
you look like but i'll just
i know i learned that today yeah the
mayor's wife and son possibly had the
worst week first the father died then a car
burst through in his funeral and find the city
they didn't think about it they did have the
worst weed also the idea that they just go
home each night like [ __ ] that's gotta be
the worst day of my life and then wake up
like we don't see them going home and just being
like oh [ __ ] and then like the next day the
brothers got it out for this kid man hood that is
awful that's really good that is [ __ ] hilarious
also potato alliance i'm going to say is because
of the vegetable and i really appreciate that
absolutely i alive myself with potatoes as well
all right lost in universal would you like to
see a robin with this batman and who would
you cast tom holland lewis tan of nightwing
lewis tan yeah as nightwing yeah i want a martial
art you would just skip to nightwing uh you could
have netwing and bloodhaven be inspired by batman
and then you could allow yourself your little kid
robin that way people get this whole bat family
they want i like batman by himself if you want a
whole bat family you gotta skip at least one rob
and have bloodhaven be nightwing inspired by the
batman bring in jason todd crowbar that kid but
a big part of nightwing's dna is that he like
kind of [ __ ] got pissed off at batman he like
but i don't know if if pattinson's old enough
or will be old enough yet to have like because the
kid's gonna have to be a kid five-year-old robin
batman's like 28 in this i always imagine
nightwing as like taking over nightwing at
like 26. so i don't think you can do an
arc of nightwing unless you do like five
of these movies i think you'd have to
do a younger robin more of a jason todd
if or tim drake even but i don't and and
tim drake would actually work for that kid
in the movie better but anyway i don't
know if we could get a dick grayson arc
yeah see my guitar detective series
that i've been pitching throughout this
livestream uh was going to take place right after
the death uh like the opening would be the death
of jason todd and then it'd be like a cut to a
few years later i could see that and then say the
robin would be tim drake and nightwing already
exists that's what i'm kind of implying is like
have you raise one robin and another one's already
a precedent and they mentioned bloodhaven already
yeah so maybe make it more you know inspired
by man was going to be played by seth rogen
park stackhouse just says steve buscemi is rob
hello there fellow kids andrew saw you guys at
amc city walk on friday i was too chicken to
say hi love you guys andrew we would have hugged
you and breathed don't come up to us don't you
talk don't come up to us but you go up to koi
yeah he wants the attention i can't tell this
is sarcastic or not because it rings so true
guys i work on the internet i need to know
there's a voice going somewhere was olivia
in the chat people saying chalamet where's
olivia hey olivia may be a great robin hey
sorry i'm ignoring you john's supposed to be
monitoring the chat am i though there have
been times where you're like we gotta get back to
this ignore the chat john i've been doing my best
to acknowledge the chat over here when it's
appropriate uh i i i only see the message of
you of us ignoring you i'm so sorry olivia let
me do a word search now no no no no okay andrew
probably got to see pattinson not us right now
because i didn't see that oh yeah dude okay look
look guys if you are ever if you ever recognize
us anywhere first off i want you to realize we are
so much bigger than the normal people you see we
are like wow it's like oh my god i watch you guys
all the time this is bizarre seeing you and they
are not normal people yeah uh so i want you to
lead with that energy of putting us on a pedestal
that we absolutely deserve michael shannon
and then maybe consider approaching us with
money if you want to talk to them but slowly
be prepared to purchase prepare to purchase the
handshake yeah that's how we did it photo 25
here's to interactive if you're speaking with us
the meter is running it's like an old school cab
exactly we are the taxi cab of fun encounters in
real life if we click yes yeah let's let me start
the time right here it's actually as you approach
because you've gotten to see me so frankly i've
already started the clock it's based on icons yeah
as soon as we register one another charging yeah
sorry you'll be built yeah in real life uh we are
uh we're really nice said you just come up to us
we want to talk we we want to be approached i also
love talking about comics with people like it's
the coolest thing to be like oh this thing that
i thought no one else enjoyed is now a market so
yeah come come say hi i've seen i've had people
as it happens more often than movie if honestly
if i'm at a theater my favorite place if someone
does approach us is at a movie theater that that's
actually my favorite place to if if someone does
come up dinner's a little weird i've had some
weird like i'm eating and my mouth is full and i
don't know how long you're gonna what do i do but
otherwise yeah i've had it because there's just
like a weird like do i stop do you wanna keep
eating sometimes you can tell there's someone
staring at you and i'm just like and if you're
gonna play the staring game this doesn't happen
it doesn't happen a lot honestly but if you're
gonna play the staring game i just prefer you
come say hi because i'm we're not like gonna be
like get the [ __ ] away from you someone had me
sign a comic the other day that made me so proud
is you don't have to write one in particular you
could sign any kind because i do that you're the
comic guy yeah we gotta we gotta get some merch
man yeah that's right merch [ __ ] there's three
of us talking about michael shannon just a big
big position guys we gotta move on i heard a
little danny elfman btas soundtrack when the
bombs go off and batman looks out the window
and sees the water flooding the score in this
film is the best also zoe kravitz as catwoman
someone pointed this out in the comments in our
um new rockstars vid was that that bombs go off on
the 5th of november remember remember oh that's
clever as election day but also you know v for
vendetta that's awesome i love that great call
great call someone also zoe kravitz oof indeed
craig stratton zoeva kravitz is my favorite
catwoman now you should have said meow right
there right now ledrock one shapiro hating
it's cemented it is a 10 out of 10 for me
agreed i thought you were declaring
something by your sink ledrock won and
text fist bump to all right
that sounds like a tasty beverage eric atkinson
thoughts on joker being the founder of drops
let's slow down coy what's drops drops is
a drug in a few continuities and the actual
drophead guy is straight from the comic books
which was really cool to see but drock's is like
a very addictive narcotic slight hallucinogen
depending on which which arc you're reading
uh but it's very batman-based truck yeah
they explored some of that in the gotham show
yeah that's cool i like the gotham show this is um
the gotham show hour he doesn't get enough credit
and it does a lot of the things that
people say that they want in the movies
a poster who has spotted make sure all of our
moon knight coverage is about agents of shield
it will be there are lots of potential tie-ins my
friend i will enlighten you on all of them agent
carter hey i know how captain carter's coming to
uh doctor strange agent carter is terrific there
it is a great show too for the entire multiverse
if you at least watch asian carter that's great
but the people are excited because she's in
what if yeah not because of your card agent
carter is so good it's good i know it's good tv
i've heard there's a second part of this question
a poster was spotted during production of an ace
chemicals poster where the font was dripping into
drop that is really cool i never saw
that cause i actually avoided behind
the scenes of this or like paparazzi stuff
because i wanted surprises i love this idea
uh it's fun because it ties into the whole
drug like in the michael keaton batman 89
they do a really good job making it so the
nefariousness of the joker is the random
like you don't know what you can wield like
you don't know if you can use a hairdryer and
[ __ ] like poison is everywhere this would
do that nicely but in a more modernized noir
detective way co-signed what's a michael keaton
it's uh he's a guy he played birdman which is
uh this one shotter um this guy easily yeah he
thinks he's a good one we got ourselves a bird man
and then he played the vulture which is a
birdman as well i'm over dar stern he's also in
johnny dangerously a fantastic slapstick comedy no
one talks about enough guys listen to me expected
toast 59 is here he says this movie was incredible
saw it early today it was nearly jumping out of
my seat really happened i was overwhelmed back
a half hour in i was jumping out of my seat i
need to get comfortable to leave it's so awesome
and the riddler was so scary love the portrayal
thank you for saying the riddle was scary because
i thought he was too but those are rated bros they
were just like not scary enough he's kind of scary
yeah he's curious yeah and the portrayal like the
the venom not vain venom but like the vitriol that
came out of him it was an intimidating performance
well and when the others when the others show up
at the end that genuinely made my heart drop of
like oh that's sinister like yeah yeah we talked
about even in the trailer of like there's got to
be probably more people in his cult or whatever
but i'd forgotten all about that and that moment
really hit that and when i i'll never forget the
first time when when the mayor steps out and the
tv flashes and finally see him standing right
there like that oh man that's such a good moment
a perfect moment that in fact that is the perfect
moment i think for me you know what surprised me
every time i watch this movie the commissioner's
voice is so high yeah oh my god and that one cops
also the one cops voice of the mustache that
like yeah yeah he's like sticks here john
we got ourselves a situation you really trust
this guy jim it works because the movie is so
stylized but in any other movie that i don't know
that guy's got his one the commissioner's voice
always throws me off so mickey mouse every
time i saw you in the trailer man i did not
imagine that [ __ ] all these wheezy guys running
gotham's law before what's he doing here hey ron
vigilante and michael that's
mitchell all right give him the room
she's gonna get higher and higher as this
goes give him the room guys everybody
a moment of silence for thomas and martha did
you know ray kroc was also in the army with
walt disney i did not know that for that ryan
thank you romwe and ryan agreed if i ever get my
animations off the ground you're selling the toys
buddy watching you guys makes me think that how
wonderful neapolitan ice cream is except
two of the thirds of vanilla this time
i'm out into pure awesomeness thanks ryan leonard
but if you approach us approach us with cash
in person if you ever recognize us i just imagine
people recognizing us but for whatever reason
it's just playing out as the prologue through
binoculars they're just watching us walk to the
box office eventually they'll come in the back
of the theater i've made friends at the gym from
guys who were like dude i watched the room and and
i just that there are plenty of times i'm talking
to them and i come home i could tell they want to
now leave the conversation you're a fan of that
how you keep people from harassing you is you
make them one i'm like and now you're shackling
like you're in here with me now i see you dodging
me at the gym when i'm trying to say hi to you
i hope he's watching his stream i feel like yeah
i can see especially the gym that's fitting uh
arnov's what did you think of batman's game not
a lot but he still packed a punch i don't know
his back too much it wasn't big enough like
they were like look how much about bats and
i'm like they're still this game boy yeah he
works out sometimes yeah i like robert patton's
skinny boy yeah arnov singh thank you for the
momento de silencio hunter coulter do you think
it would be a good idea to bring in the bat
family somewhere along the way or even just
a robin or how about alicia silverstone bring her
back it all depends on tone and how you handle it
i think it rot matt robert pattinson wants a robin
real bad we present him a lot yeah he just really
he wants one in real life i think he could do some
really interesting character work because he's
playing such a young boy that's stifled so it'd be
cool to see him as a paternal figure exactly yeah
his whole character is traumatized from not having
his parents and they show that really beautifully
and that's what i mean it would be such an
interesting i think it would be fascinating
to do it with a great actor robert patson and tom
hall yes yes mr wayne oh crap oh crap he would be
like the michael sarah in in lego batman what's
that movie they did together the netflix movies
holy [ __ ] no one pointed out
i was recording the whole time i
forgot jacob bible oh the author of the bible
oh dude your autobiography is amazing actually
might be maybe just the theater i went to but
you could tell the children who grew up on disney
marvel violence were pretty uncomfortable
i mean even if you didn't grow up on the
disney marvel violence he's uncomfortable
too it's not not intense like it's a very
there are adults who are like that's
a little uncomfortable that's a lot
hey alan t wants to know did you like the part
where bully mcguire showed up i i did i loved
it you got some dirt in your head i love ha
ha and then batman just looks at him and goes
karen taylor hey guys matt reed super chat oh
golly thank you uh hey guys matt reeves understood
that bruce and batman is a broken person who
watches bruce wayne and thought yeah that guy
is a vigilante vengeance thoughts robert
pattinson is phenomenal in this movie nah
he's too skinny to be the best little [ __ ]
guy this [ __ ] guy doesn't even do his car
i'm not worried about bruises this is a
little boy get your boy to lift some weights
jim two sizes too big that jacket
is there's no way he's the best
that actually is a good point like he definitely
his his weakness and his innocence does definitely
deter you from thinking he's back no that's what
i think he doesn't come across he's brooding but
he doesn't come across strong well they make
him swim in that suit too like this suit looks
big for him and they have the and when he is in
the suit they also show he's super suit reliant
to survive yeah like he gets shot a lot he does
kind of walk into god nobody aims at his mouth
yeah hey enough said new york the dark knight
came out 14 years ago and it stood the test of
time do you think the people will still be
talking about the batman 14 years from now
yeah 13 years and then it abruptly stops i found
myself watching scenes from the dark knight just
the other day of like heath ledger scenes being
like is this [ __ ] still as good as i remember
it is and i'm like man this [ __ ] is still [
__ ] this [ __ ] yeah it's still a cinnabon that
i honestly think this movie is like i said at the
top like it's gonna be the thing that keeps this
medium and genre going because it's so different
so unique and now i can see this causing like a
ripple through the comic book movie industry we'll
see more things taken seriously to this level
so i i think we'll look back on this like we
look at iron man 08 yeah this this movie has an a
minus cinemas that's [ __ ] i really was i was
concerned this would be more divisive yeah i was
concerned i doubted the people yeah i did too i
doubted the public and i was wrong i was like look
i think it's great but then again on tick-tock
i'm getting attacked left and right because
people are like [ __ ] you this is the batman
like the snyder center center and like that's
why i think my animosity is not fair because it's
not the actual people it's the vocal minority of
people that are attacking the movie because it's
not their batman but that's it's an archetypal
character like there's so many takes not all
snyder verse fans are jerks i i just said us a
vocal minority i'm acknowledging that i was just
lying to not upset the sniders okay that's fair
what they've done for charity and
everything i respect 99 yeah i
feel in many ways like a part of that but i
don't attack people about that that's what i mean
yeah oh yeah i think people are still going to be
talking about this movie especially because batman
had like i feel like batman is the james bond of
comic book movies and spider-man is the doctor who
where like they both where you going
let someone know that i'm still filming
you can go you can leave no i'm not get
out of here you can go no we don't like you
chris cox go home thank you for the very
generous sc love you guys thank you buddy
make money over here big money this is why i do
live chats like a big big talk to him more you
think they'll do no man's land i feel like it'd be
kind of weird to do it right away well they also
kind of did no man's land with dark knight rises
like they they did something definitely they did
some of the story elements recently enough do you
know what happens in the fifth season of gotham
is it no man it is a hundred percent no man's
land i think that's a fifth movie thing like
i think you can do it after a couple robins
are dead it's supposed to be like in a puck
see i thought about that too but then when you see
when you see the end of the uh the batman
like some of the shots especially with like
catwoman you're looking at the streets i'm
like okay they're cleaning up a lot of this
yeah it's not as like criminals have taken over
everything you know yeah it's more like zero
years yeah which is the the and then they said
martial law was initiated and so it sounds like
people will also be coming in to help and they
can as opposed to donating which is like no one
could come in yeah yeah national guard's coming
it's way too recent to have no man's land after
gotham apparently season five but also dark knight
rises like you can't do that yet yeah you gotta
build up to no man's land but i think in like
you know four or five movies it'd be cool yeah
just in the next movie insert the wonder woman no
man's land scene boom done dude it's a good scene
mike k do you think robert pattinson will be
the type of bruce wayne to create a matches
malone party oh this is a dope question mike k
yes i actually think of any bruce wayne actor
the one who will make personas is the
one that does not yet have a persona like
the the identity of bruce wayne right now is
the most malleable so it'd be really cool to see
him develop the bruce wayne persona as a
playboy as well as a matches malone tech
detective it's kind of like he's uh to to
people that don't know match the moment he's
kind of like patched to logan which is probably
even more obscure reference he's a very uh he's
well done now you got two to explain i literally
just explained something nerdy with nerdier um
he is a persona within inside a persona as a way
to uh hone in on stuff and mislead others like
so logan with a patch on is this guy that runs
madrapore [ __ ] i'm just getting deeper in the
hole uh madrapore is an area in mutandum where
uh crime and villainy and madrapore is in uh a
falcon in the winter soldier and it's a it's
a land a mutant hive of another personality
man it's not that hard another detective and in
madrid of certain crime elements william faison
did you guys hear adam west batman
theme in the movie at certain points
i swear i heard hints of it overall amazing with
this i thought i heard more elfman sometimes he
said he used all of the prior batman's to assemble
his sound so maybe they're going to hear that
fraud what's a remix um yeah so i i think
you might have i don't know adam west batman
at all so i can't speak to that i want dr dre to
score the next movement yeah we forgot about him
we did nowadays everybody wants to talk about
miguel martinez i love this movie so much
what batman video game has the same viber theme as
the movie what game should i play i would say uh
play la noire and then chase it with arca i'm
uh yeah definitely the arkham games maybe more
because there's some slight tone variations
between arkham city and arkham knight
i would say maybe more akin to arkham knight
perhaps but you know bruce batman eventually
talks more he has to talk more oh yeah
he can't just stay this great forever
not just not only does bruce wayne have to adopt a
personality but batman eventually talks a lot more
i mean he talks more in this movie than any
other as far as like sheer dialogue batman like
he [ __ ] goes him and catwoman all the detective
stuff there's a lot of talking yeah but i'm saying
uh you know like uh i think there's a little like
i think a little bit of that kevin conrad can go
along oh i see you're saying okay yeah like
those long holds are gonna be less and less
so though yeah a little bit of kevin costner goes
a long way i mean it is a water world setup dude
ezra west i hope the edward elliott name drop
isn't just an easter egg i want pattinson to
play both hiro and villain in one of the sequels
how confused would people be if that would be
like because i know that we know as hush fans like
what that is but imagine someone's just like well
there's another rubber pens was a also be a fun
way to do like a posh clay face combo i was going
to say can you explain that with a more obscure
reference how can you do clay face in this world
you can't do it oh you can't he's just always
getting plastic surgery so that's hush so so hush
so hush is a guy that grew up with the waynes
and he is a master plastic surgeon so he's able
to change his face and like he's he's been in
the shadows for a lot of bruce's life and he
appears as a guy in a trench coat with a very
wrapped face and he's a really cool villain uh
the hush story line involves most of the iconic
batman rogues it's a really cool detective story
because you don't think it's going to be a guy
from your childhood that sudden change your
face uh so at one point he can look like bruce
i don't know if they'll go that extreme because
that seems very uh face off uh for this universe
but uh maybe we get nicholas cage elliott oh my
god i want it they should remake face off with
dwayne johnson and kevin hart i want to make
money i want twins with kevin hart that would be
also great right or mel gibson and danny glover
oh robbie brown directed by milk gifts genuine
british pound hey guys love from scotland
who do you guys think would be the worst villain
in the future buttons and films i think a killer
moth would be hilarious and my leaves can pull
anything off condiment i want in this scottish
condiment condiment king i want bruce
wayne to stroll up in a subway king's just
oh my god you can also bridge the
blood gap with ketchup there it is
everybody now you can make the
r-rated movie you want to get a cat
guys we're going adam west with this
condiment king that's what people want
plus they need a new mayor maybe they get a
king instead nerd collision we got a speed round
this movie could be oscar worthy paul
dano best supporting actor the batman
best picture for 2023 maybe rpad for the best
actor nomination yes john collison i agree all
the oscar nominations i would love that it
won't happen but also colin farrell should
get some love for this i think colin farrell
disappointing i think this should definitely
have makeup it'll get all right it's better
yet it'll give us better than the nomination uh
joaquin phoenix joker or jared leto joker debut
batman 2 movie with robert pattinson riddler
and scarecrow and joker team up against batman i
don't want a single one of those jokers to touch
no disrespect to moises uh but but joaquin
phoenix's joker already met bruce wayne
uh you could do some uh timey wimey flashpoint
hi jinx if you want to make that story work and
stretch it also the idea of joaquin phoenix's
uh joker being an unreliable narrator you could
have him think of thomas wayne as corrupt in
canon of this universe because basically you
could say that thomas wayne being corrupt
by way of the riddler is a corrupt joaquin
phoenix's take on thomas wayne's those universes
could share but i'd like them not to goody
hi how are you guys we are good the dark
knight rises bane would you guys like to
see tom hardy back as that character and
go up against robert pattinson's batman
probably not but it's a cool head cannon i
don't make many any sense any sense at all
new batman um too much time ewy me
for what this universe is trying to do
i would uh actually get a new bane and
have him be played by dave bautista
i mean that's the that's the linear i like that
the fun of that choice all right or anthony starr
he's beating up people in bars now oh yeah he got
arrested he got arrested or homelander became him
john as of right now the batman made 248 248
and a half million it was also became one of the
highest grossing pandemic era film domestically
in just three dias it's also the first 100 million
dollar film from warner brothers since 2017's
it they haven't made a million opening weekend
for five years so it's a very big win for warner
brothers all around in chapter two they were like
that equates to 744 million minutes wow the money
that i did how would it do for 48.5 million people
they didn't spend a dollar on this oh i was like
i literally was like how do you just account for
you get a ticket so i think you somehow new movie
take an average price divided it multiplied it
that's bad see i was thinking you were trying to
calculate how much money per hour they made it's
like that's a very specific figure what's a dollar
a movie uh you guys see that dollar motion picture
with the batman the nickelodeon this is five cents
for everyone shows up they see the batman there's
amc surcharge [ __ ] we always do the money but we
should we should do a attendees that's that's the
tricky thing because especially the amc doing
the extra money for batman because they charge
more for batman a bunch of [ __ ] suckers well
you need to keep the theaters a lot is that why
that imac [ __ ] was so much [ __ ] money they
need to get the theaters alive was it could have
switched it out for movie moviepass i mean a-list
yeah all you guys had eight i had no actually i
thought i asked oh did you and uh because i got
it through oh you have a third third party that's
yeah i couldn't help you okay that's and that's an
issue i see all right kiefer drummond why michelle
enjoyed the movie that was the most inside of us
talking about our experience yeah i would like
kiefer grundman brady born on a daihy the scene
where he uses what i uh took to be the adrenaline
was awesome but i've heard lots of people reaching
for that to have been vietnam thoughts if you have
been listening to the stream we will know that
we full-heartedly believe that's exactly what
it is and we have echoed that sentiment non-stop
about this symbiotes are coming he's going to be
bane jay i showed up late to the stream well it's
okay because we're late to your car actually you
know what right on time we have not talked at all
about john chatturo who's incredible but have you
talked about how great carmine falcone was i loved
the scene where bruce goes to see him and was uh
and has his perception of his dad shattered you
know what i loved about this on rewatch is that
you with the creepy nature of you can tell
carmine's attracted to selena i know yeah yeah
it's so uncomfortable the way he says beautiful in
a different the way he like strokes her face oh he
like is attracted to her and he has no idea yeah
it's that old boy [ __ ] yeah there's some people
haven't seen spoilers for old boy um but i i do
think falcone like what an incredible take because
you have to see him manipulate bruce in real
time and then you have to see alfred like
undo that damage in a back-to-back scene and
falcone the whole time felt intimidating enough
to have something over penguin i believe it was
a hierarchy of power i believed him i believe
and then then he goes to alfond and then i was
manipulated with bruce yeah which is beautiful
that was crazy and that's why he's a leader like
that's what he's able to do for crime i think like
when we did our non-spoiler i i think chatura was
like one of the first people i brought up because
he surprised me in terms of how much presence he
had in the movie yeah uh yeah he's excellent 24
years ago today big lebowski very different from
tom wilkinson i like your daddy squeal like a pig
i love you dog like a dog here's what he says i
i loved seeing john turturro just play that like
really relaxed menace yeah he's like almost he's
like he's so unconcerned sunglasses at night
just [ __ ] vibing i'm a guy i'm running
this club i'm gonna be over here oh that
yeah like i just love his leg is is like
calm tense energy uh hyman john jaymen john
abandoned terminal station was bat cave hell
yeah i love that too i love that his entrance
was through the wayne like infrastructure because
we always have the dwayne train but this was a
way to twist that wayne train with the bain bean
train pop culture oh but i did notice when he um
goes down to the terminus he has to like take his
bike down the stairs how does he get his car out
good suspension he's got he's got it
on like those low rider hydraulics
it's my favorite training
scene it's really [ __ ] great
he's training before fighting superman as
if this training is gonna do oh it helps
yeah boston you're trained to be pet superman
from boston i know i love how you view every
boston actress their character is from boston
even in space bill burr is space boston ben
affleck no one can tell you from boston everyone
from boston stays from boston it's a prerogative
guys that's how it goes i don't like the rules
hey pop culture podcast what's up sir how you
doing bud i think the kid batman safe could become
robin robin he just never gets away from trauma
just had a rough week and now a rough life
phencyclidine craig stratton hey shouts out
to you buddy i know you've been like asking us to
come back and do some stuff one day it'll happen
uh craig stratton paul dano riddler is also one
of the best comic book movie villains close to
ledger's joker i think he was a great comic
book villain i don't think anyone uh i think
heath's joker is like up there with brando and
and paul thomas i think uh yeah like i'm sorry
what's his name papa timer sanderson's the actor i
mentioned earlier he's retired now he's a cobbler
uh daniel day-lewis i think like daniel
day-lewis caliber performance from heath
dia de los you figured it out yeah i was just
like his hands on my shoulder that's comforting
the more i've seen this movie the
more i really am enamored with the
paul danos yeah can you imagine that they got
down they lose out to play someone played kite man
mike dropped goddammit daniel davis moose the
scene with joker is needed beyond a studio
note it gives riddler the real win he wanted
denied by batman and delivered by joker's riddle
a friend he had friends they were out of
seven square cars they were gonna die for
them yeah um i i hear you that it did give
riddler some closure and that is important
but i also think that makes it even more of a
post-credit scene because the end of the movie
being batman victorious adjacent with hope in the
the town all that and then you end it with like by
the way the arkham villains are still the winners
like that's batman to me so yes i agree with you
but i would still restructure joseph curtis the
third act was incredible feeling the despair in
bruce when he realizes riddler's plan and how he
influenced him amazing how did you feel about that
that was one of the elements that unfolded the
most overviewings to me and especially the second
and the third time really seeing the the change
in that scene where i'm like oh dang riddler
really was inspired by this guy and thought he
would be right on board with him and and i love
i love what that says about batman i love what
that says about the riddler all that stuff
i really liked uh the dynamic oh yeah no it's like
the the interrogation scene of like the philosophy
of what batman represents in the dark knight is
really what's cool about the way it's played out
in the arkham scene and here with the riddler
and batman is you know it's kind of similar
in in the way of like where they're saying
who batman really is and batman's like no
you're garbage [ __ ] you you know i don't
know i don't agree with your assessment
but then when the guy says i'm vengeance that's
him realizing the riddler was right yeah you know
it's it's powerful that's why i don't understand
the people hating on the third actor like this
they're not [ __ ] owns well they think the
[ __ ] the bombing and all that it comes late
in the like out of nowhere but i'm like no he's
this whole time he's been purging the city he's
purging from the corruption and started cleaning
up the streets in his own [ __ ] up sadistic way
because he thinks batman would be on board
for this it's a great third act it's a great
conclusion that isn't just someone punching each
other master thief what if joker is being set up
for the sequel and they could finish off with the
court of owls also i highly recommend a righteous
gemstones on hbo has been recommended to
me a lot lately yeah i've heard that a lot
let's get walton goggins in this universe dude
i would love i would love that for the court
of alas to be in here everyone wants the court
of owls but you know what yeah i wanted to okay
i think moyes's sobrano would run like a girl from
batman most people would yeah i would i would in a
second you see i'm sprinting away i wouldn't i'd
be that dumb guy at the beginning of the movie
who are you supposed to be then i'd
be all the other idiots who would be
like all right let's fight him that went
well for our friends yeah we are the only
criminals not afraid you might be the thing
we've been hearing about the past year
we should fight him yeah guys we could take him
uh lazzy warrior thank you for the momento diesel
hungry the raider nation 33 robs bruce is
the real bruce damaged alone grieving angry
has trouble connecting to people cause of
fear of losing those he cares about again
you can feel the struggle and the pain it's
almost as if there's something in the way
ah raider nation thank you for saying that
beautifully said yes yes big fan of the food
food fighter song dude i love dave grohl
and the way he sings that song is so good
ryan platts the way i see it gotham is flooded
and ends in and ends on november sequel idea
is mr freeze comes in around crimbus and freezes
gotham to complete eyes but it's not flooded
anymore if when the scenes in catwoman you see
this a lot of the streets are back to normal
at the very end yeah yeah we don't know what
time they should be maybe they're on high
ground let's pull up the cemetery let's pull up
uh a bootleg right now let's just watch it again
yeah all right guys see you guys watch this
an hour ago that is now being claimed
impressive youtube that you do this would happen
yummy pancakes how you doing buddy from
the patreon make your danny pancakes maybe
we can sleep i do like the ryan ryan's idea
about it being like a use the holidays like
because that's very long halloween calendar
manish but i don't know if that can work yet
you know in a batman movie with more time spent
there's only one holiday between october 31st to
november 6th uh took a half day on friday to watch
the flick got out of the theater uh during rush
and i would mutter i am finished anytime another
driver angered me oh dude you just made that
chase just makes you want to drive through some
kind of big tube and blow it up with the front
of your barracuda hocus pocus your nan i can't
your name's too long for me to finish reading
it and i want to because it seems like it's a
cool name but i loved the scene when nirvana
hits and he monologues well he makes uh while i oh
golly oh no way back what are you doing what have
you done well he makes his way back to the bad
cave i got ryan gosling vibes from the beginning
of drive with night call playing love the vids i
want everyone to know i was the first he actually
called me and said that i was the first youtuber
to say that he's like ryan gosling from drive i
first want to say it on the internet this one
it's ryan gosling i don't ever want to know this
he would be badass but every time he speaks
every criminal would be like what what's that i'm
huh also the musta if they did the mo like i keep
thinking of the other guys but he's got the videos
that's actually the nice guys the
other guy stars a boston actor
mark wahlberg that takes place in boston
because mark wahlberg is in it does it not
like uncharted they found treasure all throughout
boston yeah that's boston harbor that's where that
ship is boston harbor that's where america was
founded i feel like if alfred wasn't in bruce's
life he would be completely over the edge i feel
like alfred and bruce uh the alfred bruce moment
at the hospital allowed bruce to step back into
the light and let him connect you know on repeat
viewings the alfred relationship grew for me it
was one of my weak points in the first feeling but
it's subtle uh and i do think that alfred even
with his limited screen time is a good anchor for
bruce that i think will develop in the coming
films but i i agree with you not enough dory
though frankly yeah who was she she forgot she's
she's she's a creation for the phlegm unless
there's no do you know dory is i was making a
finding nemo reference but do you know who dory is
no the old lady who lives at wayne manor oh yeah
no i forgot like nemo the one who takes her to
answer the phones yeah what's she doing she's just
been letting the phone ring for an hour hello she
actually got that phone call before the bomb went
off and i was just trying to get there bro be
like why'd you hire this old lady it's story well
and i was sitting there during the movie thinking
to myself is this them doing that preemptive
sound mix or is alfred just ignoring the phone
yeah or i i thought no it was after did you he
called after yeah it was already an hour ago but
yeah but the way they mix that scene yeah it's
like there's there's the phone rings constantly
through the entire moment of alfred looking
through the mail i thought it was him ignoring
phone calls because he ignored the accountants
and stuff because they set up earlier that he's
been like fielding phone calls so i was like
oh i'll buy this somebody's overthought this
i think he was just focused on the mail well
and and now i'm thinking that the phone's not
even ringing in that scene it's ringing from
it's just what a super preemptive time uh
sound overlapping something in the way
you're throwing it because you're capturing
from batman's perspective right he thinks he's
calling him before this bomb happens and then
so he's imagining he's picturing it he's
picturing alfred's slowly opening mail
he's slowly getting it out for them away he
just reads he opens mail just doing his outfit
life of nate it's the scene where batman
injects himself to save selena for me where
he goes ham on that guy the whole theater
was rumbling in silence after that scene
uh and the whole theater was rumbling and the
silence of the scene also when batman walked
the people out of the flood was poetic yeah it
was stunning gorgeous full-heartedly agree with
everything you said there you know what surprised
me is that they show ridler getting caught in the
trail turning pretty much allowing himself
to get kevin spacey in the trailer yeah it
worked for me because by the time it happened
i was like oh i forgot i saw this like i didn't
i definitely i did not forget that i saw that
yeah the whole third act is the trailers and
the whole time i was like i forgot all of this oh
lucky well i don't i stopped watching trailers at
the after the one we did see that's probably
why i've watched that trailer so many times
gl jr justice league batman is the world's
greatest detective yet he never figures out
the clues on time even the riddler thought he was
a disappointing year too i mean there's a lot of
uh a lot of shit's kind of given to him he's
yeah he's better than the cops at least gordon
yeah he's better than the cops he's he's yeah
gotham's greatest detective currently and he
will evolve and he will be the world's soon
enough even though he never leaves gotham
doesn't even mean much that's true he's working
on it guys he's worried ernie bird the stoner
really disappointed with the joker barry
would have been a great mad hatter in my
opinion i'd rather have matt reeves
punisher movie than another batman
lost me at the end there i was with you yeah
i would uh i i think that was a rumor mill
for a while was that oh my god is he
going to be mad hatter or joker a lot
there a lot of person who's mad hatter but bad
joker nah all right guys we're almost joke hat
we're almost done all right it's that time of
the stream that's why you can't start off too
strong i did i did monologues i was like don't
worry you gotta reel them in my second win
not until we're done matt mercer's mad hatter
coy davis who's that guy look guys
i just need to grab some cashews
do it oh i'll be right back all right i'm gonna
share with the class i'd like some cashews
oh no but you need to hit
the remote yeah we're done
everyone's in the dark okay i'm okay so we're
caught up on the the here we go we're back to the
uh we will wait for you to get back we'll
cruise them no we'll do it all right here we
go we're jumping back into stream labs greg will
return momentarily cashews for everybody yeah
william faizon is back uh the batmobile on
imax the batmobile sequence was so orgasmic
the sound design shots practical effects batman
walking up to penguin reeves is goat cosigned
absolutely and i read i love upside down shots
especially with elements where it's like fires
burning upside down water's dripping up like it's
it's such a slow effect shot was so and it was
just so simple and apparently they found it in the
visual effects edit like they didn't plan all of
that to that level they were going to do awesome
so it was a cool little like it worked beautiful
beautiful all right jay on yt carmine falcone kind
of reminds me of adam sandler and uncut gems am
i crazy or do you see it too your mangoes let's
get some sandals let's get some ad damn sandals
until now but i hear you dude that don't
cut gems it's a [ __ ] wild ass movie
i love that you started it at [ __ ] midnight
this is fine i'll see it eventually i'm fine
i love gold chloe davis another koi out here if
your real name is koi i'm very excited to meet you
hi real rejects love y'all after seeing the
batman i think it would be very interesting
seeing hugo strange killer croc black mask
mainly hugo strange to test batman with knowing
his identity also how about that damn batmobile
holy [ __ ] i think you go straight to the fitness
world even better than nolan's because there was
a rumor about the third movie being hugo strange
i think he'd be incredible here and i also think
with arkham as a show especially yeah i think
hugo strange is coming yeah phil crock i don't
know about that no they'll make it realistic
they'll do it like the mortal kombat short baraka
i mean the code name alligator there could be
something with the fact that the water happened
and there could be toxins and [ __ ] and it's
yeah it's a guy with like some kind of crazy
skin disease and sharp teeth or something yeah
they'll do like the origin of like just half in
the night everything flooded yeah that i think
is going to change gotham yeah that might be
like a like an oz court moment yeah pretty much
abraham this is my first batman at the theaters
oh wow congrats and oh my god was it perfection
definitely my favorite batman movie and it just
gets better every time i think about it also love
the streams especially with koi hey thanks just
giving a lot a big big mango fruit slice i love
any situation that brings koi into the room always
happy to be here i'm always happy to be near you
jake horror my dude batman too mr freeze scarecrow
side firefly with a hint to ivy batman three clay
face and ivy two face versus penguins side
anarchy batman four arkham asylum led by
joker batman five court of owls with hush and
azrael well because i feel like in this situation
it's partly my job to be over here like looking
at the levels and and and like monitoring this
stuff so that you guys can spew expertise anyway
part five court of owls with hush and asriel
calendar calendar man tease oh [ __ ] this up
john each film i gotta catch you in my throat
jake uh that's a lot um i don't know if we're
gonna get 15 villains uh but uh john's dying from
the volume of of sheer villainy you've brought
forth to the batman i'm here that said this movie
did have you know a fair amount of villains
and it made them work um but oh my god until
jon comes back i'm trying to recover it it's not
working out i'm trying so hard i like that you've
beat out a whole franchise here and i think that
sounds great we should give money to uh indiegogo
campaign you know we always start off jesus christ
you have two drinks over there drink a little bit
that cashew is just persistent
i can't drink because i'm laughing that's why i'm
trying to scratch my throat with speech literally
four hours in we've evolved so quickly you can see
the image of what we look like it's just so fun
born confused hi guys amazing movie incredible
performances from all the characters batman
and gordon duo stood up for me the cinematography
is just top notch and i have a feeling that the
batman will be nominated for best picture what
do you think good good guys i think this year
the academy is showing their hand and going
like what if we were the kids choice awards
i am a big fan of award shows and i think the
academy is supposed to be a certain type of award
show at the end the culmination of award shows
golden globes is where you get drunk kids choices
like they're all different the academy needs to
appeal to a younger demographic because that is
the viewership we're trying to reach so i do
think they need to look at genre content i
think they need a stunt award i think they need
to start looking at comic book films as as any
other film and include them in them as well but
i think it's very uh how do you do fellow kids of
them to be like fan favorite award it feels like
they're pandering and it's a little insulting
so i think next year they're either gonna have to
double down on being hoity-toity old white dudes
or we're gonna start seeing more films like this
get approached so it's gonna lean one extreme of
the other i think at the at the end of the day
this year cutting for the manger awards on the
ceremony was bad move i think the fan favorite
thing is kind of in poor taste because it
makes it like those movies aren't important unless
they're the fans we should all celebrate film so
i hope you're right we'll see all
right i've got monologue i'm leaning
do you guys think you can go on the riddler's
website he talks to us and gives riddles to solve
pretty sure ones um there's sure no one solved it
but you guys should give it a try cool video idea
i guess boss can't do it we can't do it truth
if you solve the riddle i mean that radalada.com
they've been dropping different ciphers i mean
there are a couple up and and eric vos has
decoded two of them so uh to your question yeah uh
although we have not broken any of the ciphers it
leads to like a big spoiler what if it hacks your
identity and steals your whole life it makes you
batman it makes sense it says you are now batman
it sends a bunch of emails from your account
you're back back my dude flev uh lol i don't know
how my message about deathstroke led to such a
conversation about penises but whatever the penis
the batman was a great start for this year in
superhero films can't wait to see all the movies
yes including morbius one of my spidey favorite
villains take care people are strange you know
i love the flab doors except for more bees
i you know it's that one you don't hear that too
often i'm a little excited i think it'll be fun
i don't know there's something about the
way he says that thing at the end of uh
this is michael morby is at your service for
some reason that line sold me on the whole thing
i was like that's my favorite jared leto
that's my favorite jared leto performance
right there he's done a lot of work
but him saying his name i don't know
that's a weird chris pratt
impression nobody said to me nobody
oh we should do a watch along when that's
available online [ __ ] yeah i'm rude
of uh gaussian gucci oh or more via services
but how gucci seems like we would have to do coke
for it but anyway unchained hi greg john and coy
didn't know if anyone has brought this up but
did anybody notice the upper shot of batman
next to falcone's body with the light flickering
it's about the riddle but i saw it as a subtle
nod to crime alley without doing the origin
ah interesting sure sure that's cool actually
that's a cool way to put it that's a really solid
notice man i like hearing this ronin hell yeah
we are a real hangout stream today we really
are happy to be chilling crown did you know
did you guys uh notice that the green serum batman
shot up for adrenaline and got angry uh that must
be what bane uses love you guys i'm surprised
no one's pointed out the insane easter egg that
you can see riddler in the window have you seen
that koi that window in the shot where catwoman
walks out of the club earlier i'm gonna show them
the part of the new rock stars heavy spoilers did
a video on this too i got this don't worry i don't
think i've seen what you're talking about i texted
it to a few people i was like you gotta watch
this [ __ ] in there all right text it to olivia
skip to 11 13 is exactly where i started all
right you're gonna see my reaction real time
watch wait just wait for it i'm showing him this
god damn it get to it oh
right there right yeah i see it now
immediately before the arrow even gave me it
yep you son of a [ __ ] that's incredible
i just needed the freeze frame i didn't
even need him to tell me i saw the second
[ __ ] thing that's what i'm talking
about that's so early on this is about
30 minutes into the movie that's [ __ ]
incredible that yeah dude so beautiful
boss i haven't met him yet introduce me to him i
want to know this guy just you you could just make
it happen right you set up a meeting with us i
need to meet this eric voss i hear in those comics
i gotta challenge this guy all right ugly few
really you guys don't know you can see right
there in the window very early on taking photos
of the iceberg lounge yeah people coming out
we're [ __ ] cool i don't even know all the
[ __ ] cash people coming out to all their
friends they're like ten dollars a bag ugly
those made in california we can't waste the
drought is on all right are you sure i'll be
all right i i've choked and i don't remember how
fancy these cashews were ugly few really thoughts
i'm just [ __ ] with you i just got
punished on camera i got yelled at
really thought i'm gonna pour these in your mouth
you're gonna eat this that's my favorite out of
ten juice really thought put them in your mouth
put the nuts in your mouth really thought the
d.a was talking about probably give you food
when you're around you're
thinking i gave you beers
that's true i'm usually in a cage while we're
filming really though the the d.a really thought
the d.a was talking about the court of owls when
he was rambling when the bomb was about to go off
going on about uh uh going on about their
behind everything totally an option i
definitely think you're like it was meant to be
that lead where's your messages dysfunctional
do you think that the syringe on the livestream
that the batman uses could be the same liquid
injects into himself in later movies i'll call you
what is the the answer we haven't given you that
okay all right guys we've only been live streaming
for a few hours for several days now we still got
913 people watching what an insane group we can't
stop now going back we're gonna refresh the supers
we're gonna do one more round people we're gonna
refresh the stupid chats we're gonna refresh the
stream labs one more time and then we're gonna
send you off to praise the lord is literally dying
soon somebody said i'm dying oh yes i was dying
but i got better he was dead i was like i was
worried yeah it would not leave my throat that
particle yeah i i i'm glad i didn't spray you with
starting to stream like i see other people
stream but they just seem so casual and relaxed
it's fun right yeah i love live streaming before
i've been like we got to be pro it's how we start
off when we start this off we gotta be pro now
now i'm like [ __ ] it just give me a blanket
it's christmas morning peaches sorry
if already asked uh do you all have
a favorite live-action the one from
gotham which character would you all
play i think coy could make a great
two-face yeah you deceitful [ __ ]
uh i think uh my favorite alfred is still
michael kane um and i think that i would
love to play harvey dent and i think if you know
if you [ __ ] me up with enough caffeine i play
too faced you mean enough email [ __ ] juice i'm
ready yeah i'm in i would love to play alfred
but i wouldn't do the british accent no of course
i would just be me you're authentic i would be my
sincerest i would just be like the way i sound
right do you know where my two-face is from
[ __ ] [ __ ] this [ __ ] joker kid is really [
__ ] up my business there's no difference between
harvey ten and two he's the same [ __ ] guy he's
[ __ ] but this half's [ __ ] green because the
green monster [ __ ] fenway jones was like he's
just the same guy with a coin just flipped a lot
of [ __ ] he occasionally talks in the wii but i
flip a coin like we flip kaz after the [ __ ] sock
sweep it kid i would uh want to play jonathan
crane that's who i would go for all right guys
green light this movie i static j hey guys would
you like mr wayne um i don't want to do this today
that's my office i'm just very reluctant
to help out in all the courses mr wayne
i got dishes to bust i got it
beds to turn i got mail i got
butler slowly do you think we can see we moved
to a smaller house we don't use any of this i
dust a lot and there's two of us who's this
dory person hey guys this old woman broke in
we just you just assumed she was on the payroll
she keeps hiding and brooms though i didn't know
we've been taking things and no one notices
because we got too much so much stuff hey guys
would you like to see the joker be introduced
as his version of red hood first and see him
fall in the acid this movie is going very classic
comic book so i think if there was a universe to
do the red hood storyline for batman uh joker
like that whole element where it's an actual
like cone red like yes because i think the acid
storyline needs to be fully shown if you're gonna
make it plausible and realistic that being said
i don't know if people would understand the red
hood element like i don't know if we could tell
that much story but maybe if they made the whole
movie he was the main villain but we've already
kind of met him so i don't know see like you do
the red hood in my dark detective my the stream
has been me trying to sell everyone on gotham
and pitch my detective comic series that i've
i've thought about the whole thing you would get
red hood in like the third movie i'm just gonna
watch greg's scripts that's what i that's what i
static also follows up by saying i posted my
question with streamlabs and super chat because i
thought the first didn't work anyway love you guys
love you guys all static that's sweet thank you
my heart is static for you putting me into a
shock i want the second movie to be all flashbacks
they tell you're one in year two it's i want my
the the facts in the way i want the sequel to be
year negative two and it ends with him deciding
to be come back man we just see that bruce like
slacking just being like a waste of space
yeah and then eventually it's like you know
what this city sucks i got i should really do
something i want to see the fictional movie
i kind of whether we have jeffrey gordon
your thoughts i think we're above that one
yes you know what they're doing with light year
how i want to see that but with the movie that the
wayne family was watching i want to see them watch
her just play like mystery science theater
with the wayne family oh this one killed in
2001 would that make it like antonio
banderas zoro sometimes it's a play
oh that's true only nolan though
i think i think it's usually zoro
like every version well cause it's zoro inspired
batman chill level tv has a question for greg
for greg who would win in a fight between
christian bale's batman ben affleck's batman
and robert pattinson's batman why for greg
because i know you have thoughts on this
oh dude afflecks for sure athletics will win
yeah and he'll do a one workout before the fight
that's like trying to unnecessarily exhaust his
body before fighting and then he'll show up in
the metal suit only one of these batman's from
boston that's so funny exactly [ __ ] you want
to come into my city yeah no but it's clearly
ben affleck he's going to take out these british
and welsh boys i mean the order from fighting will
go baffling bats and bale yeah we get his [ __ ]
but he would be the scariest on set bail with the
look at his ass but yeah you know yeah i love me
and then [ __ ] professor just like doing that [
__ ] punch at the beginning yes a lot of pensions
jdm edits paul david there were no like sneaking
up hanging upside down [ __ ] which i kind of wish
we got one he was lurking i wish he would sleep
upside down that one shot of him up in the club
yeah yeah before there's before he like watched
in the show yeah but i want like i love that sean
batman mckenzie's like where here it's actually
really soft here you're kind of over you really
didn't yeah you did the terminator salvation
yeah i did i did the tom the the the terminator
salvation was the one with the the sound guy
right or the the dp that kept getting in his life
yeah that's the only terminator with christian
bailey there's a reason for that because that's it
i love you well we used to listen to the remix
all the time man that was so early internet
what don't you [ __ ] understand dude anyway
actually i listened to the original you died
you hipster the original i've probably lost
count of the and it hasn't happened recently
but i've lost count on the amount of times i've
come in and and caught greg listening to either
the christian bale rant or one of the many
mel gibson's leaked voicemails just love rage
embarrassing rage moments what's funny is
the dude that he's talking to that the mic is
a buddy of mine tom like the actual guy he's
referring to as tom is like someone i know
oh so like i know that dude that likes when
i hear that now i'm like wait a second that's
someone i know being assaulted verbally by
christian bale oh we gotta unpack we should
have that guy [ __ ] ass he will watch it
with tom let's do a reaction to the rant
what is it like to relive this traumatic
experience from set said he's the nicest guy
in the world it's just like when you hear that
bail around he's just so he's so enraged he's
without knowing any of the context leading in
you're just like this is ridiculous but with
context it makes sense like he's done like 20
takes the dp's one main job is to know a shot
so he's the one [ __ ] up getting in the shot
and the fact that like it's an emotional scene
i'm i'm team bale on that ramp he's sorry he's
so mad sometimes you get angry there's no reason
to get that mad yeah it's the kind of mad where
if you're there on set you would have to like
really try hard not to kind of giggle because
it is the stage over there even mcgee was like
i'm team bale on the rant
me too i want another one
hey dm edits voldano's riddler was menacing i
was honestly shocked this movie didn't get the r
rating which riddler scene had you on the edge of
your seat mine was colson's riddles at the funeral
i i love the way he really plays that scene
like some kind of carnival barker judge yeah
and through a phone no less like he's not
physically there like it ties into the later
when he's like i'm all up here i'm not physical
and he's physically never there yeah and and
just the way that he talks to him like this look
like condescension just like you know you were
supposed to be an armed justice in the city were
you not mr coulson like it sounds like a trial
and uh yeah it's wonderful uh i i love so many
of his scenes well it's like he's putting the da
on trial yeah when the da's usually putting the
precise which is how two-face happened as well a
lot of courtroom stuff ab fabs and still alive and
he's two-faced they only blew half his face off
how did batman survive that he's got a very strong
suit it's his chin though his chin was exposed how
did he not get any cuts or bruises on his chin
too handsome he walked out perfectly fine two
things bounce off that's his superpower for reals
gareth hood it is so nice to see you after so long
what the [ __ ] girl how's it going going on
buddy and he's a car guy i think he's out in
like saudi arabia yeah okay yeah hey hope you're
doing it forever man yeah dude like i think of
you from time to week we got your card the big
card how's your kid man yeah he must be an adult
hey hope you're doing well i hope you're all
doing well thoughts on the batmobile i loved the
entrance in this movie the floor in the cinema was
shaken oh dude yes absolutely i mean so badass and
i love i don't know i love the choice of the the
make and model to go with that like barracuda and
to like make it look all roided out i like how
the car feels like a character yeah absolutely
it feels like his horse i didn't think i'd
ever have a new favorite batmobile and i do now
like i thought the one element of the burton that
stuck with me was always a batman build now this
is taking over that's pretty badass yeah it's
really impressive it's pretty ba it's about it's
more efficient than that [ __ ] one in the dark
nitrogen yeah the tumbler didn't ever work for me
somewhere seems like it's just out to destroy
the city i will save the city by [ __ ] up
its infrastructure this vehicle is designed
for you to worry as little as possible about
all the collateral damage you are about on your
city point of this car is you can drive it over
or through anything jumping over rooftops driving
over cars you were costing us so much money
millions batman you just ran over that cop car
oh i hope you get to sit in it one day i want
to see send us a picture of you and your kiddo
in the batmobile if you ever find one you can
chris alieres alirez uh how do you feel about
batman getting shot so much i think it was
his impulsiveness like he's a year two he's an
impulsive child and he's uh he just like he's very
headstrong he dives in first so i think we'll
see less and less of that as he learns how to
be batman um obviously it took its toll but it is
you know a choice to be a berserker and i think he
still has a little bit of a death wish so i think
there's a certain part of him that's like yeah
shoot me first i think that's why he got
exploded because he didn't like he literally
saw the countdown and stayed yeah he's like i
gotta ring every last bit of deduction out of
you'll learn something in these screens these
split seconds yes jim x mafia he didn't get shot
he got a shot with machine guns pistols shotguns
in the chat shotgun to the chest and to the back
so i'm glad in the end he had that one moment
where like actually took him out weak because i
was like this is kind of ridiculous not even [ __
] not one gun could take this one concussive blast
from uh the penguin gang took him down which i
which i liked and then that one and that literally
took him out like we had some moments i could see
i in this mango john you wanna hit me with a man
with that man with that man jim i'm worried this
is the one that'll kill me jim x mafia i thought
the batman turned to hulk after the serum i
love the brutality of that it's kind of like
it's kind of like um not to this level but when
jared leto gets his face pounded in fight i want
club destroy something beautiful yeah but i
love how the camera worked on it had this like
slight following with that movement the impact
of each blow and the sound design was so good
because they they had a slight like hum while also
that whistle of like ears distortion and then the
bubble bubble yeah and then patterson
turns around goes because i'm batman
this is sad never mind a whole
bevy of batman quotes came to mind and they
all tried to force their way out of my head
this one batman's really tired
venom carnate the riddler twist of being
inspired by batman makes sense and begs
the long time question of would there be
his villains without batman ever existing
i mean there would certainly be the organized
crime but that's a great question because
batman does inspire the pageantry and
the algebra and the you know extremity
that the villains also seek to embody uh but
i'm going to leave the floor open for coyotes
i feel so bad because he's the one
who should answer questions like this
i literally was just gonna say i love that in one
choice of dialogue they give us like literally
three nolan movies and that's not to despair this
you know movies but it's really impressive that
instead of doing like the card with joker and
then the the league of shadows all this stuff
they're just like what if riddler just really
want to be batman thinks they're gonna be homies
like literally it's like i think it's a really
beautiful succinct way to tell a story that's all
all the orphan wanted was a friend oh the single
orbits there are other ways other ways of getting
friends man that's true you don't have to go
to all this effort to get my very long route
the okay uh uh geraldo torres did you
guys get any arkham and telltale vibes
yes yes we did yes or no question yes
or no answer and we're moving right away
all righty we moving up we moving
up when the mouse works all right
jester's insanity small question if you've seen
it what's your opinion on the studios denying
colin farrell's cigar because penguin
is a smoker i think it would make it
uh i think he's gonna get
a cigar in the hbo max show
are you some sort of police
commissioner that's right
i'll be putting on my gun and badge the second
we get off here do you work for um i think that
atrial fibrillation i work for the penguins i
moonlight for god in your [ __ ] and your gun
you gotta listen to this vigilante um i think
the penguin is definitely gonna smoke at html
max because it's something colin farrell fought
for and i do think that i it's hard i'm really
torn because i think smoking is very very uh much
an impressionable thing when people see smoking if
they have any like history of smoking it makes
them on a smoke and i think that us moving as
far from smoking is very positive but at the same
time i think penguins should smoke so i'm excited
you mean honestly big business
should be made out of sickness
got it in the cigarette holder man
you gotta have it i think i think
it's coming in the show i think it's
gonna come to me you gotta have a smoke
original boston
uh could we finally see an actual robin no
a fake robin we will see in the sequel we'll
see an android robin sent by uh mr freeze
you can build them up like miles morales
i think it's 80 nightwing man i think inspired
by it's gonna be cool mm-hmm they should you
should do that man oh yeah dude connie t connie
genghis khan with the akg's over here connie real
friend those are lovely you know what when we were
watching all of us are dead i'm pretty sure they
have the same mics in the uh sound booth studio
that's right she said just got out of my second
viewing and loved it even more first viewing was
with us love badenson's different portrayal with
him as batman v him as bruce he's so unsure of
himself as bruce the final scene in this arena
is so emotional oh yes especially knowing you i
can imagine you just bawling your eyeballs out
you didn't what are you what are you doing being
here this chad was being so generous with us
ask for a refund and we'll deny it mike sanchez
i thought the country but thanks hey guys is this
your favorite batman movie uh find out this coming
week is it better than joker for you yes saludo's
the first half hour of
joker i'm like this movie is
so dark where's the this dark where
is the crystal oh when i got it
i got it got it i got it all right so the first
half hour of joker i'm like man this movie is so
good and then i'm like this movie is slowly losing
me this movie's not that good two this last half
hour is so good it sounds like it's a real middle
truck i'm not a big fan of um but joaquin's
always great throughout i love the weirdest i
love joker a lot the first time i saw it then
that's a rewatch i was like i think i really
only like the beginning and end of this video
joke joke i'm going to tell a joke uh
no joke joker for me suffers when you
do the thought experiment of removing batman stuff
from it and i feel like this movie might suffer
some if you were to remove the batman stuff
from it but i think there's a lot more left
in the batman than there is left in the joker
if you were to excise the batman connection
i just think the writing and joker is a little
like it's so on the nose oh yeah like nobody
nobody is a good person nobody is everyone
is terrible nothing almost trolling in its
very very linearness like to the point where
it's like if you don't like this like it's
got a weird aggression at the audience to it
it's it's yeah i mean it's like look at me
it's hard to describe it there's something
to it whereas this movie's like hey you want
to vibe and he's like let's do it noir time
and it makes sense to see all that through
his perspective and yet yeah it does just still
feel like very writ large and on the nose and
like i get it like as much as yeah and then
just chalking every logical plot hold up to
but i do think i think like i am dazzled by
the cinematography and joker and the music
and the movie everything yeah yeah like what
yeah there's a lot of joke you're still in my
top five batman's problem top six batman's
probably i don't know so it's number six
number six uh but like i i it's it's this
is superior to me yeah the superior i still
recommend joker yeah besides the fact that i feel
like there's an hour of it that i'm so iffy on
um there's a lot i like about it i just
don't think it's actually a great movie
it's disguised as a great movie that you can
go directly very obviously watch the the two of
uh but anyway nadir mooney hi guys do you think
we will have the court of owls at some point
ending on a strong one always um yes never in
fact they're going to stricken that they're
going to burn all evidence that that was ever
in the comics even and uh yeah no more chords
they should have a thing on youtube where it
just has you could read this all like just a
list of all the super chats that way people
would know if the questions are even asked
i could sift through hundreds and hundreds to make
sure yeah i'm gonna double check my own question
yeah uh hey spud 1210 thank you for the
momentum oh we got d we got some more nerd me
you were like not a strong one i believed
you are you you could have left no no no no
i just gotta pee i'm i'm riding this out i'm
with you to the end of the line you go home
have you guys visited the rata
alada website i have i sucked
i clicked the obvious thing to click and it
showed me a cipher i did not solve it i said
too much work eric voss solved the
cipher so we're good i said months
ago that wordle should have been a long game
viral campaign and when it wasn't i was out
so i did not go at least with the matrix they
did that some viral [ __ ] the website yeah
catch a split second of footage that looked way
better in a split second than when you actually
watched the actual we don't talk about matrix oh
no i think that movie might have done it for me
broken you from matrix the first one no
this is not how it was supposed to go
all right back to the chat back to the chat
this is a way longer conversation two-hour boy
conversation no well no i'll jump in that
conversation too do you feel the same as him
no but i uh you know i liked it the most out of
any of us who saw it on the day and i appreciate
it as an art piece but it's a it's a it's a weird
conflicting piece okay i'm with you there okay
like i appreciate it more as a work of art but
that's not a matrix film i'll be watching matrix
film experience blah blah i was just so looking
forward to it because the trailer is amazing still
yeah it falls in that category of like movies and
i won't even say it's a bad movie with a great
trailer but you could put it in that category of
like this trailer still sells me on an amazing
movie that's not the one i got i totally was
like i wanted a four for so long then i got
it and i was like i don't know oh man i thought
about a four like they're so though not like this
not like this matrix references zachary skulls
i actually didn't care for the riddler felt it
was perfect casting but execution was meh to
me i kept thinking let's go back to penguin
colin farrell killed it my question is if you
weren't aware i was colin farrell would you still
love it i want to ask people if they knew it
was colin farrell or not like like the average
movie goer and see what they thought of that
because part of the part of the dazzling effect
is that's colin farrell holy [ __ ] performance
itself was pretty i mean i thought i was able to
separate it i think it's great too but i kind of
wish i didn't know it was colin farrell i would
i want to yeah i want to be able to definitively
know how i would have felt but it is such a fun
performance to watch that every time he leaves
screen i'm just like bring him back and that's
why you got the show i can't wait to see that guy
long for him what a specific casting i know look
at colin farango he'd be a good penguin yeah you
had to want colin you know that like a sexy ass
irish guy i call him veronica make him repug uh i
feel like he uh probably approached them because
like he's a big batman fan um and it's getting
his kid's a big batman fan so i think that it was
colin farrell being like i want to be in a batman
quite a big batman fan he's a big bad man fan he
loves the [ __ ] bass he just did hot ones and
it made me want to be his friend dude he's the
[ __ ] best i've only met him a couple times and
every time i'm like you're as cool as you seem
in movies because he's from proto boston people
that's how it's done i gotta stumble upon his tape
without realizing he had a tape it's uh also going
to be a friend of mine i watched it frequently
it's great tape all right classic tape years ago
i was like watching it going is that called barrel
surprise
sometimes you see a phone booth and you're not
expecting it to belong to somebody you know
joel schumacher bringing it around attacking
him there it is there it is hey guys all right
how would you feel if joker entered uh
john do you remember we did that one
uh similar question oh he said he said he sent
it to the streamlabs yes but hey shouts out again
charge them again yes for the penalty of having us
read you twice miranda b 888 long time watcher but
first time catching a lie what what's up miranda
vilcomen love and appreciate all of your opinions
what would your perfect sequel look like wow out
of all the sequel questions we've been asked this
is the first time i'm like i've never thought what
my perfect sequel would look like really green um
instead of orange took me a second i like that
joke it could be nice or blue if it was if it was
okay what's the next step in batman's arc i think
he should evolve as someone that doesn't get shot
like he doesn't charge maybe doke is shot but like
no no he doesn't he doesn't charge head first and
then very literally he doesn't just choose to
be shot like he starts to develop a reason to
stay alive after the conversation with alfred so
he decides like there's a reason to live beyond
himself and then he uh needs to develop the bruce
wayne persona probably because of mr freeze in
my world um because he he wants to like help this
guy fund this this thing uh and then his his lady
gets gets you know the disease she gets and then
he's conflicted as both bruce wayne and batman
because bruce wayne knows dr freeze batman has to
know mr freeze and then you've got the conflict
between bruce and him and then like i have an
opening villain that would be you know solomon
grundy or something to get back to like how his
fighting has evolved and then at the end of the
film catwoman comes home but what is his arc as
a person he needs to help gotham without being uh
sacrificial like he grows out of his sacrificial
lamb he wants to help as a symbol he wants to be
a person that represents hope as bruce wayne by
actually contributing money he wants to represent
hope as bruce wayne by actual i mean by as batman
by being a figurehead instead of the light being
a warning it's a beacon of hope so throughout
the sequel he's becoming more hopeful as both
ruth and bruce and batman and being less reckless
so he's trying to inspire more people to do good
so basically like you pick up where the third
act goes and then you escalate and he knows that
in the second act he starts to realize that he
has to develop the bruce wayne playboy persona
because people are not as dumb like they start
to see so he's like how do i inspire people
while being this [ __ ] playblade financially
that's what i would do i love it my sequel would
be like a combination of wall street and a save
the rec center movie where all those accountants
finally show up and they're like you guys are
broke and we're kicking you out of wayne tower
and then bruce wayne's like [ __ ] alfred we
gotta make sure dory's been playing the long
game dory really just did that whole nest against
dory is and then yeah dory does the quarterback
squatters rights are crazy in gotham and this
is actually dory's we need to we sent someone on
the test to find out who's this dory character oh
golly busan hussein hey thank you for the stickers
big smile back what is this little
guy here thank you it's time to
blow these up even bigger is that
the real uncensored panda is there
is there a fake on sensor pad what
is that can you see what that is
that's like it's like a little fox oh it's a fox
holding a trophy it's a it's a little trick trophy
little head little drop head over here let's do
one more refresh but i think we are at uh we're
caught up finally oh guys we're done ten and
a half hours later yeah we did it we're done
and uh yeah the batman it's done we did as long
as the movie maybe it's coming from what it is
in the movie the batman we did it but not as long
as our i think we should go a few more hours just
to eclipse our spider-man i'm going to go to bed
now guys go to bed all right cool we are caught
up in the stream labs and we are coming next quick
speed round of these last ones and we go away okay
let's forever how many how many viewers
stuck around oh yeah that's the question
the 600 mark if we're below 600 we have failed
this city eight eleven eight eleven seven
jake horror all righty eric voss is mephisto
we're very behind let's let's jump to the to the
utmost uh yes yeah yeah vin diesel is
more of a vein trained by the league
of shadows because you know family
did you guys actually listen what
what all right guys let's take
off let's take a little photo
i could just do a screenshot actually
no john check this out oh that's not
yeah oh john you [ __ ] it up oh sorry i took
a photo recorder on the camera oh that's not
gonna be messed up though you're not going to see
the end of the thing we're supposed to be looking
at the last of the questions and all we're
doing is taking photos of ourselves when we
consume ourselves ourselves performing
turner says maybe nicholas holt as hush
i like that a lot that's also some fun
superman casting what about mel gibson as
ventriloquist uh [ __ ]
scarface it should be the doll
i like this ezra west says more ninja and stealthy
like batman bruce wayne becomes a philanthropist
hosting charities and banquets instead of
douche playboy they should go oh yeah he should
be working with the new mayor dude i like that
was the thing i liked partly the most about val
kilmer's batman was that they actually bothered
to make him like a philanthropist yeah that was
important as the cause yeah i agree with that
i like that i could get down with some of that
less of a douche and yes we will be the court of
owls when he you know reveals everything it'll
just be this office of walk in there you know
and you know you guys will have like a big life
meta moment vin diesel is freeze matt smith as
hu i would love to see matt smith in this world
matt smith this hush should be great big mo logan
says john humphrey is hush i would i would jump at
the chance for sure oh no batman broke his arms
oh no no he's just he's doing a rude run that's
how i want batman to just naruto run and headbutt
batman's just headbutts if not affleck josh brolin
is bruce wayne i could see that in a different
life it's a good like future state world uh this
riddler mustafa james you're writing this
out coy i thought you could go i'm like
yeah riddler does look a little bill gatesy
there doesn't he uh yeah [ __ ] boston alex guys
we got to end this right now john has to
go home he's got many women to attend to
right coy has one thumbs up making videos to
edit does koi's chair make him look like he
has big white grogo ears oh yeah oh i like that
yes yes you carry coin a little egg listen listen
i appreciate everyone for being here i think
you guys really helped make this live stream
something special always now uh before we go i
just want to say thank you very much for being
here he's a member of the gotham attorney's
office you guys uh you guys say helped us out
a lot thank you me talking about the batman a
lot of fun and thanks to everybody who chimed
in on our various polls the final one favorite
supporting character everyone loves paul dana
guys and the last thing i'll say is uh before
we go thank you to koi for being here and if
you have a tick tock please follow koi zhandro
on there follow koi tik tok talk he be posted
and i try to post like a third of my tick
tocks on youtube too so if you don't have
a tick tock check out youtube for show
for see you guys peace out my drive
not ending the livestream
no